Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und ich sage, hallo nach einer kleineren Pause zwischendurch, in der wir mal ein paar neue Termine machen mussten, geht es jetzt hier wieder weiter in unserer Gesprächsserie und wir wollen uns auch weiterhin über Wissenschaft unterhalten und insbesondere wollen wir uns noch ein weiteres Mal und mit Sicherheit auch nicht das letzte Mal mit dem Aspekt der Wissenschaftskommunikation befassen. Konkret steht heute im Mittelpunkt die Organisation Wissenschaft im Dialog. Und um darüber mehr zu erfahren begrüße ich Antje Boetius, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Ja Sie sind Wissenschaftlerin, kann man so sagen?
Ja mit Herz und Leib und Seele.
Und schon immer.
Genau.
Mit einem Schwerpunkt auf Biologie, konkret glaube ich Meeresbiologie.
Mhmh.
Auch das schon immer?
Schon immer. Ich bin bei der Geburt sozusagen gleich mit Mikroskop und Pipette...
Aha wie das denn?
Nein, ich habe mir eher eigentlich nicht jetzt, weil ich gar nicht wusste als Kind natürlich, was ein Wissenschaftler ist, habe ich mir eher so vorgestellt, man muss doch was raus finden über das Unbekannte. Egal was, Hauptsache unbekannt und neu und merkwürdig und fremd und weit weg und dann hatte ich irgendwie über verschiedene Umstände war es halt der Ozean und die Tiefsee. Und bevor ich jemals drüber nachgedacht habe, wie anstrengend es ist, Professor zu sein, habe ich gedacht, ich werde auf jeden Fall Meeresforscher, Tiefseeforscher, tauche hinab, begegne Kapitän Nemo und bleibe im Meer.
Okay. Straight forward nennt man das wahrscheinlich. So ist es dann auch gekommen?
Ja so ist es dann gekommen. Naja Kapitän Nemo muss ich sagen bin ich immer noch auf der Suche.
Naja, ich meine man muss ja auch noch Ziele haben. Aber über welchen Ausbildungsweg wurde das dann angegangen?
Also schon den ordentlichen. Ich habe zwar in der Schule hatte ich es mal schwer mit Naturwissenschaften. Als ich zur Schule ging war das auch noch im Unterricht eher öde. Heute wenn mein Patenkind erzählt, wie die es in der Schule machen, dann hätte ich auch Lust, nochmal zur Schule zu gehen. Aber bei mir war es damals öde bis auf wenige Ausnahmen und dann habe ich halt eher Sprachen, deutsch alles mögliche andere lieber gemacht. Weil ich auch so eine Leseratte war. Musste dann aber natürlich an die Uni Biologie studieren und habe mich da informiert und dann war es so, dass man den Schwerpunkt Meeresbiologie halt am besten in Kiel und Hamburg machen konnte. Damals war ja noch DDR, da gab es Rostock noch nicht. Man kann heute super in Rostock Meeresforschung, Meeresbiologie studieren. Und dann hatte ich mir gedacht, Hamburg, das ist sowieso die Stadt wo ich hin wollte, wegen Hafen, Schiff und so weiter und dann ist es Hamburg geworden.
Und das ist dann auch schon speziell Meeresbiologie das Studium gewesen?
Nein, das war erst mal Biologie und da war aber ein Institut, was es in der Form heute nicht mehr gibt, wo Tiefseeforschung damals in Deutschland gemacht wurde. Und ich konnte da ziemlich früh als Hiwi hin. Hiwi heißt so Hilfswissenschaftlerarbeiten, Jobs machen für die echten Wissenschaftler. Und Gott sei dank, weil das Studium war grausig. Es war ja da die Babyboomgeneration. Also wir hatten bei den Kursen Wartelisten von mehreren Jahren als Studierende und durch das Arbeiten bin ich dann eigentlich noch mehr verstärkt worden, dass so zur See fahren, forschen das ist was ich machen will. Und habe das Unistudium gar nicht in Hamburg fertig machen können. Ich bin nach Amerika gegangen, um da dann zu Ende zu studieren, weil es einfach keinen Platz, keine Kurse gab. Die Unis waren überfüllt. Und wenn man halt Laborgerät braucht, dann musste man drei Jahre warten auf seinen Kurs. Und Bafög war längst abgelaufen und so, also das war eine blöde Zeit für das Studieren. Aber war auch gut für mich, einfach weg zu gehen und zu sagen, dann mache ich den Rest in Amerika fertig, denn da bin ich dann richtig eigentlich aufgewacht und habe überhaupt entdeckt was Forschung ist und was das bedeutet, als Beruf Forscher zu sein. Das war mir an der Uni nicht klar geworden.
Was war dann da anders in den USA?
In den USA ist ja eine ganz andere Art der Universitäten. Die kosten Geld, Studenten bringen Geld und Studenten sind was wert und da war das im Gegensatz zu der Uni so, dass man, wenn man als Student angekommen ist, wurde man mit Namen begrüßt. Die Professoren haben sich bemüht, mit einem direkt im Kontakt zu sein, zu reden, einem auch das Praktische näher zu führen. Wie sieht die Arbeit aus. Ich habe auch das Gefühl auch zur Wettbewerblichkeit dort erst mal zu kommen. Also dass es eben tolle Journale gibt, in denen man veröffentlicht, die sind wichtiger als andere und all diese Sachen, das wird einem ja im Studium nicht beigebracht. Und in Amerika war das sehr nahe, dass man von Anfang an so eher das gesamte System des Forschens auch dann als Student gelernt hat und das hat mir sehr geholfen.
Das war so oder das ist immer noch so?
Ich denke mal, das ist immer noch. Das ist eigentlich noch mehr geworden. Also wenn ich heute – ich bin immer noch viel in Amerika und ich habe auch Studierende, die als Doktoranden dann kommen – und die werden viel wettbewerblicher trainiert als das bei uns der Fall ist. Hat sich viel geändert über Bachelor und Master, das gab es ja zu meiner Zeit nicht und da ist es auch ein bisschen mehr so geworden, dass man beim Lernen auch fühlt, wo bin ich eigentlich gerade, wo stehe ich mit meinem Wissen, mit meinem Lernen. Berufsbilder werden einem nahe gebracht. Es gibt auch in Bachelorkursen inzwischen so die sogenannten Softskills gibt es ein paar Angebote. Das war in Amerika alles schon, als ich studiert habe gab es das da alles schon. Also das wettbewerblichere, klarer sein, Kommunikation spielt eine wichtige Rolle. Dass man auch im zweiten Semester schon vor Wissenschaftlern steht, um mal eine Idee zu präsentieren und durchzudiskutieren, da wären wir zu meiner Zeit als Studenten noch vor Angst gestorben, wären wir so einer Situation ausgesetzt.
Aber Sie sagen, das hätte sich jetzt auch in Deutschland verändert?
Ja das hat sich verändert. Es ist noch nicht so wie es in Amerika ist, aber es hat sich ganz stark verändert. Also heute die Bachelorstudenten die können schon ganz anders auftreten und sprechen als das zu meiner Zeit war. Da saßen wir ja zu 300 im Vorlesungssaal und Noten gab es praktisch nicht an der Uni. Da hat man nach dem Abi war es das letzte Mal, dass man eine Note gesehen hat. Es gab ja nur Vordiplomprüfungen, aber eben keine Noten während des Studierens. Das mag für den Einen gut gewesen sein, aber generell hatte man kaum ein Gefühl dafür, wo stehe ich, kann ich was, habe ich was jetzt gefunden, was mir interessant vorkommt, hat ja auch keiner mit einem gesprochen damals an der Massenuni, so wie die da halt war. Ist heute auch alles anders geworden. Jedenfalls für mich war das Studium eine echte Hürde, ich fand es echt nicht gut, wie das Studium gelaufen ist.
Und wann war das denn eigentlich die Hamburger Zeit?
Also ich bin mein Abi habe ich 86 gemacht und dann bin ich sofort nach Hamburg gegangen und zwischen 86 und 92 habe ich studiert. Wobei ich eben schon 90-92 dann hauptsächlich in Amerika war.
Und ist der Grund jetzt für den Wandel in Deutschland im Wesentlichen der, dass jetzt das Bolognasystem eingeführt wurde mit Bachelor und Master oder ist das nicht auch so ein bisschen eine Folge der zunehmenden Vernetzung auch der Wissenschaftssphären?
Ja natürlich, also es ist beides. Aber im Rahmen des Bolognaprozesses, alle schimpfen darauf, aber ich finde doch ein paar Sachen sehr wichtig, also nochmal einen Restart zu machen, Curricula sich neu anzuschauen und auch ein bisschen mehr über die Berufsfähigkeit, die Employability nachzudenken, was ja doch passiert ist in dem Prozess, auch dem Prozess der Akkreditierung, da habe ich das Gefühl, das ist schon besser geworden. Ich hatte übrigens, hatte ich das Glück, früh Professor in Deutschland zu werden, aber eben an einer amerikanisch ausgerichteten Universität, der international University Bremen, wo wir vier Jahre vorher praktisch, bevor es Bologna dann da war, schon Bachelor und Master hatten, und auch so wie in Amerika die dann aufgebaut haben. Also dass man Erfahrungen sammelt nicht nur im Lernen, sondern auch gleichzeitig immer Produkte liefert als Studierender. Redet, schreibt, Ideen transportiert, Anfassprojekte macht, Casestudies und all diese Sachen, das war zu meiner Zeit so nicht an der Uni.
Diese Employability, die wird ja auch häufig kritisiert, weil sie so ein bisschen auch als Feind gesehen wird des freien Forschens, ohne wirtschaftliche Zwänge. Also in verschiedenen Debatten, auch hier kam das häufiger zur Sprache. Da ist ja sicherlich auch was dran? Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das jetzt bei der Meeresbiologie so ausmacht, das ist ja ich weiß nicht, wenn es erst mal darum geht, die unbekannten so ab 10.000 km unter dem Meer zu lösen, ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade ein Massenmarkt.
Aber wenn man diese zu Schaffen im Erwachsenwerden und darüber hinaus die Neugierde als wesentlichen Antrieb zu nutzen, ganz verschiedene Wissensformate zu kombinieren, dass man eben Unbekanntes, bekannt und anfassbar macht, das kann man für alles mögliche im Leben gebrauchen.
Ja das ist richtig.
Aber ich also Employability, das wird jetzt wieder so ein bisschen arg übertrieben, also viele stellen sich darunter vor, dass man schon am Anfang, wenn man zur Uni geht, dass man dann schon weiß, was hinten rauskommen soll. Was für einen Beruf man dann hat und dann nur genau das lernt, was passförmig ist. So funktioniert ja gar nicht die Berufswelt. Die Berufswelt will ja auch Menschen haben, die Erfahrungen gesammelt haben, die teamfähig sind oder die auch mal alleine durchhalten, belastbar sind. Also es gibt so viele komplexe Phänomene dann am Ende einen Beruf ausüben. Heute gibt es ja auch dauernd – also immer mehr auch in Deutschland – gebrochene Berufsbiografien. Man wird so alt, dass man immer wieder auch mal was neues anfangen kann. Gibt es immer öfter. Also das ist es nicht. Employability bedeutet eher so, dass man den Studierenden am Anfang vermitteln kann, was gibt es alles für Möglichkeiten mit dem was du hier für die Jahre jetzt lernst und dich mühst, was du dann da wirklich mit anfangen kannst. Und ich bin echt manchmal richtig geschockt, wenn ich mit Studierenden rede, dass die noch nicht mal – die sitzen da an der Uni für fünf Jahre – und können gar nichts dazu sagen.
Was will ich werden, was gibt es denn mal. Ja keine Ahnung, meine Mutti wollte so gerne, dass ich studiere. Aber weil es ansonsten ja auch langweilig ist oder da habe ich diese coole Zeit, da kann ich nochmal immer lang schlafen. Das ist also in meiner persönlichen Statistik leider der Studierenden, sind es echt nur 10-15%, die eine Antwort geben können, das soll dabei rauskommen, das wünsche ich mir. Man kann es sich ja auch einfach wünschen, man muss es ja gar nicht wissen, aber man könnte doch wenigstens einen Wunsch formulieren und leider finde ich, das ist immer noch schwierig und bei diesem Stichwort Employability bedeutet das, man könnte zumindest von Anfang an den Studierenden und den Professoren zusammen die Chance geben, darüber zu sprechen, wozu das Ganze, was soll da rauskommen, für was ist das gut dieses Wissen, so in dieser Form zusammenzubringen und weiterzuentwickeln? Deswegen finde ich das eigentlich ein positives Stichwort und kein Feindbild.
Welcher Forschung haben Sie sich denn dann so entgegengestellt? Also was war denn im Fokus?
Also ich habe schon immer – Biologie hat mich insofern fasziniert, weil das Leben in den Prozessen und das Leben auch in seiner Macht über die Geschichte der Erde zu verstehen, das finde ich immer noch sehr faszinierend. Chemie mochte ich auch immer ganz gerne eigentlich, weil es so unglaublich ist, dass wir alle aus ein paar Elementen bestehen, aber diese Elemente in beliebiger Form zusammengesetzt völlig anderes ergeben. Und da gibt es ja in der Chemie noch viele Aufgaben, die auch damit zu tun haben, wie könnte die Welt anders sein als sie ist. Aber in der Frage der Vielfalt des Lebens und in der Frage, was kennen wir alles noch nicht, was auf der Erde lebt? Was für Anpassungen gibt es an Dynamik in der Umwelt. Das fand ich noch immer am interessantesten, und da war es aber immer die Wechselwirkung auch wieder zur Erde. Also was man Geosphären-Biosphären-Interaktionen nimmt.
Wie gestalten sich Leben und die Erde gegenseitig. Das ist ein super Thema und das hat so viele Berührungsaspekte auch zu dem, wie wir eben mit der Welt umgehen, dass ich froh bin, dass ich mich auf die Biologie konzentriert habe und eben vor allen Dingen Ökologie, Ökosystemforschung, wo es wirklich auch um übergreifende Verständnisfragen geht und nicht nur um das Einzelne im Kleinsten kennengelernt zu haben, sondern auch Dinge einfach zusammenzuziehen, Synthese zu betreiben und aber auch unsicheres Wissen zu bedenken. Das finde ich sehr spannend.
Ja in gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja auch wirklich topaktuell alles.
Das ist auf jeden Fall aktuell. Also es ist manchmal beruhigend inaktuell, wenn man über Leben in der Tiefsee forscht, dann hat man auch irgendwo einen geschützten Raum, wo man wirklich in Ruhe nachdenken kann, weil es doch nicht so ist, dass es jetzt sofort für irgendwas gut oder wert ist. Das ist auch schön, so forschen zu können. Aber inzwischen ist es doch auch für vieles gut, im Sinne von dem Verständnis, dass wir an Land doch den Ozean mitgestalten und dass wir einfach aufpassen müssen, was wir tun, da nützt dieses Erkennen, was lebt dort, sehr, um das auch zu formulieren und mit Leuten drüber zu sprechen.
Gab es denn auch so richtig Forschungsfahrten so mit dem Schiff in die Antarktis oder?
Absolut. Das ist mein Hauptding. Ich habe jetzt glaube ich gerade meine 45. Expedition hinter mir und ich versuche, seit ich – ja – seit ich angefangen habe, überhaupt in der Meeresforschung zu sein, im Sinne von das erste Mal zur See zu fahren, muss ich 1-3 Monate vom Jahr halt auch wieder da raus.
Ich sehe schon. Also eine gewisse Passion zur Wissenschaft kann man Ihnen nicht absprechen. Wenn man sich jetzt so intensiv mit der Forschung auseinandersetzt und dann halt auch Ergebnisse erzielt, Papers macht, auf Konferenzen ist, so in diesem ganzen Wissenschaftstrubel richtig eintaucht und da sich natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht sich auch so eine eigene Marke schafft und merkt, wie strahlt Wissenschaft ab, wie strahlt man selber ab innerhalb dieses Systems. Ich hatte hier vor ein paar Ausgaben mit Onur Güntürkün schon gesprochen, den Sie sicherlich kennen, Sie nicken schon genau, sehr schönes Gespräch über eben auch im Prinzip dieselbe Frage, Wissenschaftskommunikation, wie betreibt man sie? Und zwar nicht nur so im Sinne von, Wissenschaft in der Öffentlichkeit, sondern eben auch schon angefangen, Kommunikation im eigenen Team, Kommunikation innerhalb der eigenen Institution und dann eben in verschiedenen Schritten bis in die Öffentlichkeit, sowohl in die wissenschaftliche Öffentlichkeit als auch in die allgemeine Öffentlichkeit hinaus.
Wann begann denn das bei Ihnen, dass so diese Fronten – wenn man sie so nennen möchte – sich abgezeichnet haben, welche Erfahrungen haben Sie da sammeln können?
Ich hatte noch nie da irgendwelche Fronten oder Grenzen im Gehirn und wundere mich heute auch manchmal, dass die Leute das so schubladenmäßig oder spartenmäßig immer gegeneinander aufstellen, weil ich selber mir mein Bild von der Welt über Bücher zusammengesteckt habe. Als Kind war ich totaler Einzelgänger, habe immer nur gelesen und nicht viel kommuniziert, aber ich habe mir so ein Bild von Wissen und Information und Lernen, wo Vergangenheit, Gegenwart und Zukunft ineinanderfließen und sich gegenseitig befruchten können und auch alle Gesellschaftssysteme es wert sind, miteinander in Kontakt zu halten. Ich fühle mich nicht als Wissenschaftler unbedingt so völlig anders befähigt zu kommunizieren als als anderer Mensch, nicht weniger nicht mehr. Aber ich bin in der Lage eben meine Zeit Gott sei dank und das Geld was ich dafür kriege so einzusetzen, dass ich an der Front des Wissens arbeiten kann. Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, dann bin ich aber auch schuldig dafür, genau diese Front des Wissens, die man sich selber mühsam erarbeitet, auch gleich weiterzugeben.
Ich finde das schrecklich, dass es so unglaublich lange dauert von dem Wissen, was da eigentlich ist in der Wissenschaft, bis dass es mal in einem Lehrbuch steht. Oder bis man dieses Wissen, was ja spannend und schön und aufregend ist und manchmal auch schrecklich mühsam, dass das irgendwo ankommt in der Gesellschaft, das ist ja unglaublich lange. Und dann noch bis es zu irgendwelchen Handlungen und Entscheidungen führt, und da finde ich das eine wichtige wissenschaftliche Aufgabe, weil Wissenschaft eben Wissenschaft schaffen ist, das schneller zu machen. Und das geht am besten durch reden.
Durch reden.
Durch reden?
Ja. Miteinander reden, kommunizieren. Wir haben natürlich in der Wissenschaft die Pflicht, Schreiben zu veröffentlichen und das haltbar dadurch zu machen, dass es aufgeschrieben ist. Sprache ist also, das Reden sind ja sehr vergängliche Momente, die man da schafft. Natürlich Podcasts, da ist es dann anders. Dann klebt es im Universum und man kann es immer wieder abrufen.
Generell?
Ja, das wird mindestens noch 500 Jahre angehört hier dieses Gespräch.
Ja, aber trotzdem ist es vergänglicher das Reden als das Schreiben. Aber das Reden ist halt direkter und schneller und man spürt auch immer sofort, was die Menschen dann zurückfragen oder denken. Beim Schreiben schreibt man ja für sich. Das klebt dann irgendwo und man kriegt gar keine Antwort und deswegen ist es mir immer wichtig gewesen, ich kann auch während ich Veröffentlichungen schreibe auch gleichzeitig immer reden über das was ich gerade gelernt habe. Einfach das ist meine Motivation für die Wissenschaftskommunikation zuallererst. Also die die jetzt aus der Wissenschaft kommen. Da will ich gar niemanden bekehren oder irgendwie so was, ich will einfach nur das was ich arbeite halt irgendwie einbringen. Und da ist reden der schnellste Weg.
Ja okay. Aber liegt ja auch nicht unbedingt jetzt erst mal jedem. Das ist das eine. Aber ich wollte auch noch so ein bisschen auf etwas anderes hinaus und da ich das Wort Front jetzt vielleicht nicht besonders glücklich gewählt habe, aber ich hatte das auch schon im Gespräch mit Onur Güntürkün, dass man dann eben schon sieht, oh jetzt habe ich hier Erkenntnisse gewonnen und jetzt möchte ich gerne auch meine Wissenschaftscommunity, sei es jetzt nur die Konferenz, auf der ich etwas präsentiere, auch überzeugen. Was hilft es, wenn ich viel forsche und wenn ich nicht in der Lage bin, diese gewonnenen Erkenntnisse, von denen ich vielleicht total selbst überzeugt bin, dass das jetzt die großartigste Entdeckung seit geschnitten Brot ist, dass die anderen dem auf folgen. Ich meine, da gibt es natürlich viele Widerstände, viele Leute, die sagen wir mal, erst mal prinzipiell gegen alles sind, was ihre Thesen verwirft. Aber keine Ahnung. Man muss das ja auch kommunizieren und man muss ja auch die richtigen Formate finden.
Und was ja auch noch so ein Teilaspekt ist, da kommen wir glaube ich auch schon so langsam ein bisschen zu der Organisation, man muss ja auch der Öffentlichkeit klarmachen sowohl natürlich die Bedeutung der Wissenschaft, eben als auch die Konsequenzen darauf. Also gerade bei der Meeresbiologie denke ich mir, ist ja auch so eine der Wissenschaften, in der sehr viele Erkenntnisse gerade gewonnen werden über Auswirkungen von den Änderungen von Ökosystemen, die ja dann letzten Endes – und auch da sind wir wieder bei diesem Turnaround – ja möglichst schnell eine Änderung des Verhaltens der Gesellschaft und damit natürlich auch der politischen Lenkung dieses Verhaltens der Gesellschaft erfordert. Das muss ja, das birgt ja sicher ein hohes Frustrationspotenzial, wenn man sieht, so wissen wir das eigentlich, aber es wird nicht verstanden, es wird nicht beherzigt. Oder selbst wenn es verstanden wird, wird es trotzdem nicht umgesetzt.
Ja. Aber da ist ja eben diese verschiedenen Formate, die die Wissenschaft hat zum Kommunizieren, die passen schon alle irgendwo zusammen. Das eine ist natürlich, man muss auch eine Qualität des Wissens erzeugen. Es wird einem dann geglaubt, wenn man die Wege benutzt, die die Wissenschaft sich erarbeitet hat, wie ist etwas sicheres robustes Wissen was auch hält. Und das ist die eine Sache, die dauert halt lang, die braucht Geduld, das ist eben aber dafür abgesichertes Wissen. Dann gibt es natürlich das Wissen, was ziemlich direkt vermittelt wird oder wo ich mich mit Wissenschaftlern streiten kann zum Beispiel das habe ich gesehen, was bedeutet das? Dann habe ich eine Hypothese, dann stelle ich die in den Raum, dann können andere mit ihren Erfahrungen sich daran abmühen und die versuchen, in Frage zu stellen, zu falsifizieren, dann kann ich zurück geben, meine Experimente verändern. Dafür haben wir ja in der Wissenschaft sehr gut aufgestellte Plattformen und Räume. Wir haben die Fachgemeinschaften, wir haben die Konferenzen.
Aber was immer mehr mir zu schwinden scheint sind die Begegnungsräume, wo Wissenschaft und Wissenschaft und Wissenschaft miteinander spricht. Weil in diesem Expertentum, in dem Entwickeln in den Fachgemeinschaften, die auch immer wieder sich verändern, die sich aufspalten in neue Fachgemeinschaften, dort ist es unheimlich schwer geworden, sich wieder zu begegnen mit Fachgemeinschaften, die ganz weit weg sind und versuchen, Wissen anders quer zu vernetzen.
Die Blasenbildung.
Das macht manchmal die Dinge so wahnsinnig langsam. Also da ist es zum Beispiel jetzt bei uns, ich sage jetzt mal irgendeine Frage, ich beschäftige mich mit Vielfalt. Also warum gibt es so viele verschiedene Tiefseelebewesen von denen es alle wenig gibt, warum gibt es nicht vielleicht von bestimmten Tiefseefischen, Tiefseequallen, Tiefseekraken meinetwegen eine super erfolgreiche Art, die alle Weltmeere besiedelt. Ist ja alles dunkel, kalt und hoher Druck. Aber nein, überall sehen die anders aus, unglaublich vielfältig, aber immer nur wenige davon. Was soll das? Was steckt dahinter hinter diesem Konzept? Jetzt könnte ich mich bei Fragen der Vielfaltforschung, wozu ist Vielfalt gut, muss ich mich ja nicht nur jetzt mit den weltweiten Tiefseeforschern, die über Vielfalt nachdenken, unbedingt darüber unterhalten. Sondern ich könnte vielleicht auch schnell und mehr lernen, wenn ich jetzt mit Soziologen, die über Vielfalt in der Gesellschaft nachdenken, wenn ich mit denen spreche, die haben eine ganz andere Herangehensweisen, vielleicht haben die Konzepte gefunden oder auch Indikatoren für Wert, von Vielfalt, die nützlich sind, über was ganz anderes zu übertragen.
Und hier mache ich mir Sorgen und finde, dass Wissenschaftskommunikation auch eben Kommunikation in der Wissenschaft aber über die starken disziplinären Grenzen sein muss und das können wir nicht unbedingt so richtig gut. Da gibt es auch wenig Förderformate, gibt es auch wenig Begegnungsmöglichkeiten, weil das alles Zeit kostet und Geld kostet und Zeit wieder in seinem Alltag zu finden und zu sagen, ich bin zwar ein Meeresbiologe, aber ich könnte jetzt auch mal mit einem Soziologen oder Politologen oder Mediziner über meine Forschung selber reden, das ist kaum der Fall. Das ist ein Punkt, wo es vielleicht Fronten gibt, die zu überwinden sind, die interessant sind.
Ja kommen wir doch vielleicht mal zu der Organisation, die ich schon angesprochen habe, Wissenschaft im Dialog ist glaube ich eine gemeinnützige GmbH, wurde von verschiedenen Wissenschaftsorganisationen hier in Deutschland gegründet. Der Stifterverband für die deutsche Wissenschaft ist einer davon. Die haben jetzt den Vorsitz übernommen vor drei Monaten glaube ich?
Vom Lenkungsausschuss ja.
Vom Lenkungsausschuss, ahja okay. Das heißt dann was?
Das heißt lenken. Also es gibt praktisch ein Büro, wo die Leute, die wirklich beim Wissenschaft im Dialog arbeiten zusammensitzen. Das sind inzwischen fast 40 Menschen, die für uns arbeiten, dass Wissenschaftskommunikation weiterentwickelt wird, ausprobiert wird für alle großen Forschungsorganisationen und verschiedene Stiftungen und die Idee ist, ich bin da ja erst neu, habe erst im Januar angefangen, aber die Idee, die ich so wichtig finde, ist, dass die Wissenschaft sich insgesamt drum kümmern muss, wie transportieren wir das Wissen zu allen möglichen verschiedenen Gruppen hin. Also zwischen Wissenschaftsorganisationen und innerhalb der Wissenschaft, aber auch raus zu den Bürgern, raus zur Politik, zu den Kindern, zu ganz verschiedenen, zur Wirtschaft meinetwegen, also ganz verschiedene Zielgruppen gibt es ja oder Empfänger für den Sender.
Und wenn jetzt jeder für sich, also die Leibnizgemeinschaft, Helmholtz, Max-Planck, DFG, wenn die alles für sich selber ausprobieren müssten, dann wären die unheimlich viel Zeit gebunden, unheimlich viele Menschen gebunden, immer wieder hier und da ein bisschen was ausprobieren und das zusammen zu machen, das ist ja unheimlich wertvoll. Und dafür ist Wissenschaft im Dialog erst mal da, dass sozusagen auch die gewisse Wettbewerblichkeit zwischen Forschungsorganisationen mal aufgehoben ist und alle zusammen daran arbeiten, wie stellen wir uns vor, was für Formate sind eigentlich nützlich, um besser Wissen zu transportieren. Und dafür gibt es einen Lenkungsausschuss, da sind eben diese verschiedenen Forschungsorganisationen alle drin und die senden dort meistens hin ihre Topöffentlichkeitsarbeiter. Ihre Leute, die zuständig sind für Medien, für Kommunikation.
Und die zusammen sind dann eben und treffen sich und reden über die Weiterentwicklung von den Aufgaben bei Wissenschaft im Dialog von den Projekten, die wir haben. Es gibt auch sehr viele Drittmittelprojekte, man entwickelt dauernd neue Ideen weiter. WiD hat auch europäische Projekte, ist Partner in Projekten, also es ist sehr dynamisch und war jetzt auch stark am Wachsen in letzter Zeit.
Dazu muss man ja sagen, das ist jetzt nichts komplett neues, sondern das gibt es schon eine Weile, seit 1999, da ist es mal gegründet worden. Jetzt haben Sie gesagt, Formate darum geht es. Also erst mal so die Suche nach dem Wie. Was sind denn die Formate, die WiD jetzt so geboren hat, um diese Ziele zu unterstützen?
Was vielleicht am meisten bekannt ist, ist unser Schiff, was über Deutschlands Flüsse fährt, die MS Wissenschaft. Und die Ausstellungen, die die Wissenschaftler machen, die von Wissenschaftlern kommen zu den Menschen in die Städte, zumindest die die ein Hafen haben, transportiert. Wir haben ja dieses Jahr das Thema Zukunftsstadt und das Schiff ist gerade unterwegs und zeigt von allen möglichen Ideen der Wissenschaft, von wie haben Städte früher ausgesehen, wie haben die sich verändert bis hin die Zukunft der Stadt. Mit was für Materialien werden wir in der Zukunft in der Stadt leben. Können wir unser Essen in der Stadt selber wachsen. Wie kann die Stadt ein Wohnraum werden, in dem wir uns alle zu Hause fühlen. Wie sieht es mit Elektromobilität aus, kann man zum Job fliegen? Also dieser ganze Blick von, wo kommen wir her bis wo wollen wir hin, wird dort auf dem Schiff mit sehr viel Experimentier- und Mitmachmöglichkeiten dargestellt.
Das ist also so praktisch Ausstellung modern zum Mitmachen, aber eher würde man sagen, ein konservatives Modell, weil man dort reingeht als Mensch und mit Dingen spielt und sich vielleicht da mit den Ausstellungslotsen unterhält, aber man bringt sich wenig ein. Man spielt, aber man hinterlässt, man kann auch was schreiben oder so, aber man hinterlässt nicht so sehr Spuren.
Was ist das für ein Schiff?
Das ist ein Binnenschiff, Frachtschiff. Wird von einem Kapitänsehepaar betrieben, die auch selber über die Zukunft der Binnenschifffahrt nachdenkt und die geben ihr zu Hause sozusagen her, damit dort die Wissenschaft sich austoben kann und dann Leute kommen und das Schiff besuchen. Das ist ein echtes Schiff, das kann auch tatsächlich Fracht transportieren.
Und also kann oder macht es auch?
Macht es zwischendrin auch ja. Das ist nicht immer für uns unterwegs und wenn es eben leer ist kann man es pachten für andere. Es wird auch manchmal von anderen als Ausstellungsschiff benutzt. MS Wissenschaft kann aber auch immer noch ganz andere Dinge transportieren als Wissen. Finde ich aber eine super Idee, weil zu denken, dass eben das Wissen im Bauch des Schiffes durch die Lande fährt, das gefällt mir zumindest als Seefahrtsbegeisterter sehr gut.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und kommen wir zum ganz anderen Ende der Formate. Es sind jetzt eben eher die Beteiligungs- und die Mitmachformate gefragt. Also manchmal ist die Wissenschaft unzufrieden, dass es halt also die Leute gucken auf einen, der Wissenschaftler im Elfenbeinturm, wo sind die Berührungspunkte, sind wir wirklich so weltfremd, wie es einem oft vorgeworfen wird? Und was ein spannender Trend ist, ist eben, kann man zusammen Wissenschaften. Also Leute, die eben nicht Wissenschaftler sind und Wissenschaftler können die zusammen was bauen, das basteln, was entwerfen, was ausdiskutieren und dazu gibt es verschiedene Bürgerbeteiligungsformate und da wird viel ausprobiert von den einfach auch wieder sich nur treffen und was ausdiskutieren bis hin zu wirklichem Basteln. Also Hack the City jetzt im Rahmen des Zukunftsstadtprojektes. Bürger treffen sich mit zum Beispiel Wissenschaftlern von Fraunhofer und bauen was für ihre Stadt oder entwerfen Software für bestimmte Zwecke, das ist das andere Ende der Formate, die wir derzeit pflegen.
Was ist die konkrete Ausprägung dieses Hack the Citys? Also wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Sind das so Tagesveranstaltungen oder …
Nein, da wird über längere Zeit zusammen gearbeitet. Also es gibt ein paar Städte, die das aufgebaut haben. Das ist sehr aufwendig muss man sagen, weil man ja eben, damit was rauskommt, dann ja auch sich treffen muss. Und Wissenschaftler und Bürger und Schüler haben dann auch einen festen Ort, wo sie zusammen arbeiten und dann über Dinge nachdenken und wirklich auch was bauen oder entwerfen. Das ist ein sehr aufwendiges Format, aber es ist auch sehr spannend, weil dann auch was bleibt, von dem was man zusammen gemacht hat. Das ist eben nicht nur mal sich treffen und ein bisschen diskutieren, sondern das ist auch, der eine lernt wie Wissenschaft geht, der Wissenschaftler lernt, wo sind jetzt eben, was kann ich als Wissenschaftler tun, aber wo können andere Leute vielleicht kreativer arbeiten, als wir das in der Wissenschaft noch können?
Ja ich schau hier gerade mal, also hier gibt es ja konkrete Ankündigungen dann für so Kickoffs.
Dresden ist am Arbeiten. Projekte, die da drin laufen ist, Stadtbegrünung, Stadtnahrung, Fahrrad als Transportmittel, Fahrradwege. Ich habe gelesen, eins gibt es auch über Sitzmöglichkeiten in der Stadt. Jetzt haben wir halt eben das Thema Zukunftsstadt, deswegen ist so viel was Bezug hat auf Wohnen und Leben und Stadt.
Aber an wen wendet sich denn das? Also wer ist denn jetzt hier gefragt?
Gefragt sind wir alle. Das ist ein ganz offenes Format, wo Menschen gefragt sind, die gerne mitgestalten wollen. Die Ideen haben und die denen vielleicht es auch komisch vorkommt, dass wir zum Teil in Städten noch mit Stadtbaukonzepten oder Verkehrswegen arbeiten, die überholt sind, die ganz anders laufen könnten. Das muss alles gar nicht viel Geld kosten, aber man kann durch Eigenengagement und Eigenaktion ja unbedingt auch seine Stadt wohnlicher machen und die sind da angesprochen. Also Macher, Gestalter, Kreative.
Ja Hacker würde ich jetzt fast mal sagen.
Ach Sie wollen auf Ihr Lieblingsstichwort.
Naja ich meine es steckt ja hier im Namen, das finde ich natürlich sehr interessant. Hacking ist ja nun ein Wort, was so über mehrere Jahrzehnte versucht hat, sich so ein bisschen von so einer negativen Konnotation zu befreien. Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass das in den letzten Jahren ganz gut gelungen ist. Es gibt ja mehrere Projekte. Ähnliches Format, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist, Jugend hackt. Da gibt es wohl auch schon eine gewisse Kooperation, die sich ja jetzt explizit so an die Jüngsten wendet. Ich glaube, da geht es dann irgendwie schon mit 11-12 los, wo dann wirklich illustre Projekte realisiert werden an diesen Veranstaltungswochenenden. Ist das hier so ähnlich gedacht? Also Hack the City schlägt jetzt quasi an einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt in einer Stadt auf und dann kann man sich da anmelden, da hinkommen und sagen, okay ich forsch jetzt hier mal für ein paar Tage mit, aber die Hoffnung ist schon, dass daraus was längeres entsteht. Also dass man jetzt nicht nur an diesen zwei Tagen was macht, sondern dass man dort mit Leuten in Kontakt kommt, wo man sich dann wie einbringt, wenn man nicht Teil des wissenschaftlichen Systems ist? Also das frage ich mich jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen.
Hand anlegen. Mitmachen. Es ist sozusagen ein Begegnungsraum, ein Labor, in dem jetzt die Regel, dass man nur Wissenschaftler ist, wenn man wo angestellt ist, an einer Organisation, die Wissenschaft betreibt und dafür bezahlt wird, dass man dann trotzdem mitmachen kann und gegenseitig eben kreatives, aktives Potenzial abschöpft.
Das heißt da wird aber jetzt schon auch mit Forschungsinstituten zusammen gearbeitet?
Da sind Forscher dabei, absolut.
Die sich dann mit der Verkehrsproblematik dann zum Beispiel auch beschäftigen?
Ja, die bringen dann eben Daten und Wissen ein, aber haben auch was davon, weil da kommen Ideen auf einen ganz anderen Weg dann eben in den Raum rein.
Ja.
Und das ist sehr spannend, das anzuschauen. Aber wie gesagt, man könnte es jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass es jetzt andere Teile der Wissenschaft ersetzt, das ist ein zusätzliches Angebot, was halt ausprobiert, wie kann man tatsächlich in dem wissenschaftlichen Prozess auch wieder mehr freie kreative Ideen abschöpfen und einbringen, was sind die Wege dafür. Es muss ja trotzdem Mitspiel- und Randbedingungen geben, es würde nicht funktionieren, wenn das jetzt eine offene Tür wäre und da jeden Tag andere 100 Menschen rein laufen, weil man will ja was zusammen bauen, was zusammen arbeiten. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein gutes Format. Und dann gibt es natürlich viel breiter aufgestellt überhaupt Citizen Science Formate. Das heißt also tatsächlich jetzt Menschen, die der Wissenschaft helfen, Daten zu erheben zum Beispiel oder Projekte zu befördern. In manchen Bereichen der Wissenschaft gibt es das schon immer, wie zum Beispiel in der Biodiversitätsforschung werden schon immer viele Daten von Menschen erhoben, die zum Beispiel Vogelliebhaber sind, die sich super gut auskennen mit, welcher Vogel fliegt vor.
Die schreiben dann ins Internet zum Beispiel ihre Beobachtungen rein und daraus entsteht dann ein Datenbild. So was gibt es ja schon länger. Aber kann man so was systematischer und unter welchen Randbedingungen auch in der Wissenschaft nutzen. Da ist einiges an Arbeit zu tun, weil wir sehr hohe Qualitätsstandards in der Wissenschaft haben, die eben die Beteiligung von Nichtwissenschaftlern eigentlich erst mal ausschließen, aber das nicht unbedingt so machen müssen, wenn wir alle wissen, über was wir reden, in dem was zu beforschen ist und in den Daten, die zu erheben sind. Und da passiert gerade viel. Hier in Berlin ist ja das Naturkundemuseum federführend für Fragen von Bürgerbeteiligung in so Vielfaltforschung, da werden auch neue Formate gemacht. Beim WED??? wird es breiter aufgestellt, da können also verschiedene Gruppen zusammenkommen und sich eben über ihre Erfahrungen austauschen und man kann gucken, für was ist das alles noch zu gebrauchen?
Es gibt ja da völlig neue Trends. Zum Beispiel diese ganzen Gesundheitsapps, die man auf dem iPhone hat, es gibt in der Meeresforschung ein super Projekt von dem Sohn von Jacques Cousteau, der hat mit allen Hobbytauchern, die sollen wo sie rumschwimmen ein Foto machen, das Foto einreichen, 2-3 Messungen dazu und dann hat man auf einmal ein ganz schnelles Bild vom Zustand der Korallenriffe weltweit. Also wie kann man eigentlich auch unsere Digitalisierung, unsere Medien, die wir heute alle haben Handys dabei. Ich habe gerade gestern raus gelesen, dass inzwischen im Durchschnitt zumindest jeder Mensch auf der Erde ein Handy hat, das finde ich unglaublich. Also es gibt 7 Milliarden Handys und die können alle Fotos machen und damit kann man den Zustand der Welt sehr schnell und auch doch objektiv beschreiben, wenn man ein paar hat.
Nicht nur Fotos, sondern auch ganz andere Sensoriken.
Geräusche.
Beschleunigungssensoren etc. Messen ja schon so einiges.
Super.
Ja da sehe ich aber eine ganze Menge Potenzial und finde es auch sehr interessant, dass da offensichtlich so ein Wandel auch stattfindet. Weil gerade diese Absch... - also nicht dieser Vorwurf des Wissenschaftlers in seinem Elfenbeinturm, der sich sozusagen mit dem Pöbel nicht abgibt, der vielleicht auch ein bisschen mitspielen will, ich denke, die Zeiten sind ein bisschen vorbei und man wäre ja jetzt eigentlich auch kein guter Wissenschaftler, wenn man nicht diese Gelegenheit auch nutzen würde. Aber geht es jetzt wirklich nur so um Datensammeln?
Ach wir brauchen einfach die ganze Bandbreite. Also es ist schon wieder eine heiße Diskussion jetzt ausgebrochen. Gibt es jetzt schon wieder zu viel Bürgerbeteiligung? Also wird Wissenschaft schlechter, weil sich jeder einmischen will, weil die Fragen dann so vergesellschaftlicht werden, was uns ja echt in Bedrängnisse bringen kann auch. Aber im Moment geht es erst mal drum, es geht immer darum, nicht nur im Moment, die Vielfalt des Entstehens von Wissen und des Bewahrens von Wissen und des Kommunizierens von Wissen besser zu nutzen. Und ein paar von den Grenzen, die wir uns mühsam erarbeitet haben, aus gutem Grund, weil Wissenschaft ja auch sich über die Menschengeschichte hinweg leicht hat immer wieder missbrauchen lassen, also kriegt man es mal besser hin. Können wir auch die Wissenschaft so aufstellen, dass sie nicht immer sofort politisiert von der Gesellschaft verwandelt, ausgenutzt usw. bedrängt wird. Das ist genauso eine Aufgabe, wie es eine Aufgabe ist, die Gesellschaft nicht zu verlieren. Also nicht auf einmal in eine Richtung zu marschieren und vor sich hin zu forschen, wo es wirklich keinen mehr interessiert.
Und die ganze Dimension gibt es und an all diesen Fronten müssen wir zusammen arbeiten. Und das schätze ich an den WiD-Sachen, weil das wirklich, da geht es um Experimente, da geht es um neue Formate, um Sachen ausprobieren. Und das ist sehr wichtig, dass wir so einen Freiraum auch haben in der Wissenschaft, wo nicht jeder gleich seine Marke, sein Logo, sein irgendwas draufkleben muss, sondern es eben um das Weiterentwickeln geht, deswegen bin ich sehr froh um diesen Job im Lenkungsausschuss.
Ja. Das konkrete Projekt dazu scheint mir dann das Bürger schaffen Wissen zu sein.
Genau.
Was sich hier als Citizen Science Plattform vorstellt. Plattform im Sinne von, dass es hier ein Verzeichnis gibt von Projekten, an denen man sich beteiligen kann?
Das gibt es, aber es gibt auch eben die Begegnungsräume. Also weil ja jeder auch wieder was lernt von diesem gemeinsamen Arbeiten und Datenerheben. Was für Verfahren eignen sich eigentlich besonders für die verschiedenen Disziplinen in der Wissenschaft? Wer kann es nutzen? Wo bringt es nichts, wo klappt es nicht, weil dann eben die Standardisierung zum Beispiel der Datenerhebung nicht funktioniert? Es gibt ja auch Bereiche, da ist es einfach schwierig mit Citizen Science, weil wir Datenschutz haben. Zum Beispiel die Frage bei medizinischen Anwendungen. Können sich kranke Menschen, können sich Patientenverbände einfach sagen, wir wollen eine schnellere Medizin, wir schreiben jetzt alles auf, wie es uns geht und kleben unsere Adresse und Kontonummer dran. Nein, das geht natürlich nicht, damit können Ärzte nicht arbeiten oder Medizinforscher, weil wir diese Daten nicht mal von A nach B schieben können. Also da gibt es echt viel zu tun und Citizen Science Plattform redet also über die Methodik, redet über die Pros und Cons der Nutzung für die Wissenschaft. Erfindet aber auch eben neue Formate und Möglichkeiten des Austauschs, aber auch eben wieder der Qualitätsüberprüfung.
Wie viele Projekte sind da hier so in der Datenbank so drin? Gefühlt sind es ja eine ganze Menge.
Oh ja, das wächst. Also es gibt vieles. Und manchmal denkt man auch gar nicht darüber nach, was alles eigentlich auch dazu gehört. In gewisser Weise gehören ja auch bestimmte Umfrageformate dazu, also das werden immer mehr und sie teilen sich auf auch nach der Art der Beteiligung und sie teilen sich auf nach ihrem Nutzen für verschiedene Fachgemeinschaften.
Ich bin hier gerade ganz...
Auswendig kann ich die Zahl nicht, aber ich denke wir sind schon in den müsste bei 100 oder mehr sein, die wir gesammelt haben glaube ich.
Also dreistellig sagen wir mal.
Ja.
Okay. Also man kann das hier so ein bisschen durchsuchen und einschränken nach, was für Wissenschaften hier.
Ja genau, also Sie meinen jetzt, Sie wollen auf das Format sich selber beteiligen die Suchbank hinaus. Die ist ganz wichtig. Da kann man im Internet einfach nachgucken und sagen, was würde ich oder wo würde ich eigentlich gerne mitmachen. Also zum Beispiel ich möchte gerne mithelfen Käfer zu zählen in meiner Stadt oder so. Oder ich möchte gerne mit anderen Kindern zusammenarbeiten und dann suche ich halt Kind und Geisteswissenschaft und Dresden oder so.
Aber jetzt auch für Lehrer zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt ganz konkret was sucht, wo sich eine ganze Klasse engagieren kann oder wo man halt einfach so seinen eigenen Spieltrieb hier ausleben kann. Ich finde es ganz interessant, es gibt hier sogar richtig so dieses, ich möchte gerne kartieren, sammeln, schreiben, sortieren.
Gibt es da eigentlich auch Essen?
Nein Essen ist nicht dabei. Nur sortieren und auswerten. Naja okay. Aber das ist schön.
Doch das ist zum Entdecken und Beteiligung organisieren. Aber wirklich auch lernen über den Prozess, das ist wichtig.
Ist das, ich könnte mir das nur vorstellen, dass so die Nachfrage gerade bei Klassen, bei Schulen hoch ist oder zumindest hoch sein sollte. Ich weiß nicht, ist das so in dem Maße, wie man es möchte oder könnte mehr sein?
Also inzwischen in dem Unterricht heute sind ja eigentlich immer – versuchen Schulen und Lehrer auch die Kinder dazu zu bringen, die Kinder bei irgendwas wirklich mitzumachen, irgendwas selber zu gestalten. Also es gibt dieses Format einfach für sich an den Schulen ist es auch so implementiert. Das aber wieder größer zu machen, so dass eine Schulklasse das Gefühl kriegt, sie hat jetzt wirklich an was großem gearbeitet, was für ganz Deutschland wichtig ist oder so, da zum Beispiel wäre das gut, weil man dann das was die Schulklasse gemacht hat auch irgendwo wieder archiviert, bewahrt und sagt, okay so haben die das gemacht, das haben die beigetragen, dann wird es eben auch sichtbarer, was nicht jede Schule für sich organisieren kann.
Also gar nicht mehr nur so der Lerneffekt, sondern auch dieses, ich war dabei Ding.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also die Beteiligung von Nichtwissenschaftlern, das ist so ein Schwerpunkt, wie ich das jetzt hier ausmache. Aber auch die Beteiligung der Wissenschaftler steht ja im Mittelpunkt bei Wissenschaft im Dialog. Ich glaube es gibt regelmäßig so eine Konferenz im Rahmen vom WiD, wie heißt das? Forum Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Forum Wissenschaftskommunikation, genau.
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich einmal im Jahr oder?
Ja.
Wer kommt dahin?
Das ist ein mehrtägiger Workshop, da kommen dann die Leute, die für Wissenschaftskommunikation stehen an ihren Universitäten, an ihren Forschungsinstituten zusammen und beschäftigen sich vor allen Dingen mit sich selber und ihrer Zukunft. Das ist ja so, dass seit einiger Zeit, ich würde mal sagen ja schon in den letzten zwei Jahrzehnten, der Wert der Wissenschaftskommunikation immer gestiegen ist und dass sich das Feld auch professionalisiert hat. Während früher vielleicht ein Wissenschaftler mal nebenher dann geguckt hat, dass er auch mal einem Journalisten Rede und Antwort steht, oder auch mal selber gern populärwissenschaftlich geschrieben hat, geht es ja auch heute um Marken, um Profile, um Fähigkeiten, für die es dann Menschen gibt, die ganztags als Job zuständig sind, dieses Wissen weiterzutragen, zu kommunizieren, zu transferieren in andere Teile der Gesellschaft.
Das einfachste ist, dass alle Unis heutzutage PR-Abteilungen haben, die helfen, dass das was an der Uni geleistet wird irgendwie weiter zu tragen, sichtbar zu machen, auch anfassbar zu machen. Also jede Uni hat eine Webseite, man kann bei jeder Uni auch irgendwie heute raus finden, was haben die für Spuren in den Medien hinterlassen, welcher Politiker hat die mal besucht. Also das ist ein Teil und in dem Zusammenhang ist auch ein gewisser Bedarf entstanden, auch dort wieder über Qualität und Prozesse und Methoden nachzudenken. Also ist das, was PR-Abteilungen heute machen, eigentlich nur der Versuch der Markenbildung, haben die zum Teil reingegrätscht, wo früher die Wissenschaftsjournalisten gearbeitet haben, haben die denen auch vielleicht ein bisschen den Job weggenommen, weil sie selber Pressemitteilungen schreiben, selber praktisch die Übersetzer von wissenschaftlichem Wissen in eher populärwissenschaftliches Wissen sind.
Und selber publizieren können über ihre eigenen Webseiten.
So ist es. Oft sind ja auch Wissenschaftskommunikationsleute sind Wissenschaftler, haben vielleicht noch eine Doktorarbeit gemacht, dann aber erkannt, dass es ihnen mehr Spaß macht, darüber zu reden als selber diese mühsame Erarbeitung des Wissens hinzukriegen, aber es gibt dafür auch Ausbildungswege inzwischen. Es gibt auch Journalisten, die in die Wissenschaft kommen, das ist ein Trend, den ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe, immer mehr Journalisten wechseln irgendwann in ihrem Leben, vielleicht weil es so wahnsinnig hetzig ist im Mediengeschäft und werden dann Teil von der Unileitung oder gehen an die Institute selber. Also in diesem Feld entstehen doch viele neue Möglichkeiten, was zu machen, sich auszudrücken, einen Job zu finden. Und das wächst das Feld und deswegen gibt es dieses Forum, wo man sich treffen kann und auch über die Weiterentwicklung eben, die Methoden, die Formate, die Abstimmungen zu sprechen. Und das organisiert WiD und das ist sehr super.
Ich war jetzt im letzten Jahr da, bevor ich jetzt zum WiD offiziell gekommen bin, habe ich einen mitgemacht in Potsdam und mir das angeguckt und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Raum, um sich über alle Organisationen und Unis halt zu treffen und auch auszuhandeln, wie müssen wir besser werden, was ist eigentlich unsere Mission, was sind unsere Qualitätsmaßstäbe, das ist ganz wichtig das Forum.
Was sind da so die Konferenzformate? Sind das jetzt so Vorträge oder trifft man sich dann in kleinen Workshopgruppen?
Alles gemischt. Ja. Gibt es alles. Also es geht über mehrere Tage. Man hat Plenarsitzungen, da werden auch Preise verteilt für bestimmte Dinge. Zum Beispiel Science fast forward, also der Videopreis für Wissenschaft im Video wird dort vergeben. Es wird über – die Leute teilen ihr Wissen, auch um Möglichkeiten internationale Projekte aufzustellen, in der EU  zu arbeiten, Schülerparlamente europäisch. Es gibt so viele verschiedene Formate und die kommen da zusammen und berichten voneinander, wie sie arbeiten, was sie machen. Das werden aber auch echt Qualitätsansprüche ausgehandelt. Also was ist gute Wissenschaftskommunikation? Was darf ein Wissenschaftler überhaupt? Wie entfremden darf er seine wissenschaftliche Arbeit? Wie platt und allgemeinverständlich darf er sie machen? Und wie lange ist er Wissenschaftler, und wann ist er es eben nicht mehr? Das sind auch Dinge, die dort besprochen werden.
Gibt es da auch Ergebnisse? Also ich meine, endet jede Konferenz mit entsprechenden Publikationen, Erkenntnissen, gibt es eine Zusammenfassung in gewisser Hinsicht?
Ja, also was ich gesehen habe letztes Mal, es werden sehr viele Spuren über Twitter und Blogs hinterlassen. Es gibt auch immer Journalisten, die darüber schreiben, was geredet wird. Also man kann viel darüber nachlesen. Es gibt dann auch Vorhaben, die dort formuliert werden und weitergetragen werden, zum Beispiel ein Papier zu erarbeiten über Verhältnis Wissenschaftsjournalismus und Wissenschaftskommunikation an Unis oder solche Dinge. Das ist aber doch erst mal ein offenes Format, wo es hauptsächlich drum geht, sich zu treffen, kennenzulernen, Vernetzung natürlich ist wichtig. Also man kennt es ja von Konferenzen, das was nach der Konferenz passiert ist mindestens genauso wichtig, wie das was während der Konferenz passiert.
Aber es gibt jetzt kein Memorandum auf Understanding, was da verlegt wird und so?
Nein, ich glaube nicht. Nein, also das was mir gerade in den Kopf kommt ist woanders entstanden, wurde aber dort diskutiert. Aber durchaus, es gibt dort auch immer eine Selbstbewertung, also die die das organisieren müssen dann immer auf die Bühne und werden beschimpft sozusagen. So nicht, aber es gibt viele Feedbackmöglichkeiten. Eben diese Frage des Mitmachens wird dort auch diskutiert. Und was furchtbar schwer ist und ganz wichtig ist, immer wieder halt doch echt die Qualitätsfrage stellen, also was ist gute Wissenschaftskommunikation, was für Spuren hinterlässt es jetzt eigentlich? Bringt das alles irgendwas, diese Mühen? Das sind wichtige Fragen. Was für Spuren bringt die Wissenschaftskommunikation in die Veränderung auch der Gesellschaft, da haben wir viel zu tun, um zu sagen, wie messen wir das oder wie kriegen wir raus, ob sich das alles lohnt?
Welche Leute kommen da noch nicht hin, die da hinkommen sollten?
Also ich fände es gut, wenn da noch mehr mit den Medienleuten gesprochen wird. Das ist ja ein neues Konfliktfeld. Es wurde auch zuletzt...
Mit welchen Medienleuten?
Also Print, Fernsehen, alle sind ja irgendwo.
Also Journalisten?
Journalisten im weiteren Sinne, ja. - Redakteure, nicht nur die.
Also die Wissenschaftsjournalisten selber sind jetzt weniger präsent, sondern mehr PR-Teil.
Genau. Also das sind mehr die Leute, die die Wissenschaftskommunikation an den Forschungsinstituten betreiben, die sind da zunächst angesprochen. Es gibt immer Gäste. Es kommen da auch verschiedene Leute hin. Aber das ist eine Gruppe von Leuten mit denen man sich mehr beschäftigen müsste. Dann aber auch die Wissenschaftsmacher selber. Also die Leiter von Forschungsorganisationen, die immer mehr auch gezwungen werden, eine Kommunikations- und Transferstrategie mitzudenken, die müssen halt sich auch immer wieder dann mit ihren eigenen Leuten auseinandersetzen, die auch wachsen wollen, die Ideen haben, die Geld brauchen. Es ist ja sozusagen ein Extra, ein Obendrauf. Die Wissenschaft läuft, wir machen und tun das, wofür wir eigentlich bezahlt werden. Aber zusätzlich gehen wir noch in diese Aufgabe der direkten Kommunikation in die Gesellschaft. Dafür geben wir keine andere Aufgabe auf. Also ist da ständig auch ein Wettbewerb um Zeit, um Geld, um Priorisierung, um Stellen. Und deswegen muss man es auch von der Seite der Lenkung der Strategiefähigkeit betrachten. Und das muss bestimmt auch noch mehr eingebaut werden, dass es da Austauschmöglichkeiten gibt.
Ist viel so nebenbei, eben der Web-Video-Wettbewerb, also der Preis, der hier ausgegeben wird, fast forward Science. Wie lange gibt es das jetzt schon? Wahrscheinlich noch nicht so lange oder?
Das weiß ich nicht, das kann ich nicht sagen, wie lange es das schon gibt.
Aber gibt es auf jeden Fall. Und das wird dann auf dem Forum sozusagen prämiert, bekannt gegeben?
Genau. Da gibt es halt die Endauswahl. Also da können Leute einfach ein Video von ihrer Forschung oder ihrer Idee über Forschung und Wissenschaft einreichen. Bei dem wo ich dabei war, da war zum Beispiel einfach ein Schüler, der hat versucht, Wissen was er selber lernt, sofort umzusetzen in Filmchen und ist so ein YouTube-Held dabei geworden. Und dann gab es aber auch vom DESI zum Beispiel einen fantastischen Film über das was man eigentlich gar nicht zeigen kann, nämlich Teilchen, Teilchenphysik. Auch von deren eigenen Wissenschaftskommunikation zusammen mit einem Doktoranden aufgestellt, der Dinge erklärt hat. Also dieser Spaß am Erklären, am Erkennen, am Reden wird dort eben visualisiert. Auch manchmal sind da Animations dabei, Cartoons und so, das ist sehr vielfältig und es ist halt lustig, weil für die, die nicht immer nur hören wollen, sondern gerne gucken, die sowieso gerne vielleicht YouTube nutzen, um zu lachen über Katzen und über Schminktipps und über sonst wie was, die können sich halt auch mit Wissenschaft dort beschäftigen. Und ich finde das total genial, was da raus gekommen ist.
Der Unterhaltungsaspekt scheint ohnehin eine große Rolle zu spielen im Wissenschaftsbereich. Es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit auch diese Science-Slams. Die sich, vermute ich mal, aus dieser Poetry-Slam-Bewegung wahrscheinlich herausbewegt haben, die also auch so ein bisschen versucht hat, so die langweilige Gedichtskunst unterhaltsam unters Volk zu bringen und in dieser Mutmaßung, dass Wissenschaft so per se auch erst mal als langweilig angesehen wird, das sehen natürlich Wissenschaftler ganz anders. Und vor allem die, die es besonders anders sehen, gehen dann halt gerne auf die Bühne. Science-Slams finden überall in Deutschland, sicherlich nicht nur in Deutschland, aber in Deutschland gibt es eine ganz starke Gruppe, die das regelmäßig macht. Wo dann auch jedes Jahr ein Gewinner vom Publikum gewählt wird, per Akklamation.
Ja.
Ist das Konzept bei WiD auch in irgendeiner Form?
Ja also in Zusammenarbeit wieder mit Veranstaltern werden diese Slamformate auch mal dahin getragen, wo Wissenschaft sonst nicht stattfindet. Ich habe es selber einmal ausprobiert, da war ich unterwegs in so einem Hamburger Nachtclub. Und das ist lustig, wenn man als Wissenschaftler ganz raus, also aus dem Vortragssaal heraus in eine olle Kneipe geht oder sich mitten auf einen Platz stellt in der Stadt, so wie ein Marktschreier und in ganz anderen Umgebungen versucht, Wissenschaft zu kommunizieren. Weil das irgendwo zu einer Entfremdung erst mal führt. Da steht man ganz anders da, redet mit ganz anderen Menschen, muss mit anderen Mitteln auf sich aufmerksam machen und wird dann halt auch noch gezwungen für das, wo man meinetwegen fünf Jahre lang akribisch dran geforscht hat, das in 5 Minuten oder 10 Minuten auf den Punkt zu bringen. So dass es jemand anders auch verstehen kann und dann man irgendwie das Gefühl kriegt, da ist was geflossen. Da ist irgendwie Energie geflossen, weil wir ja miteinander was besprochen haben oder weil ich das Erkennen in den Augen der Anderen gesehen habe.
Und wenn es halt wie in Hamburg dann tätowierte Rocker sind, vor denen ich gestanden habe und über den arktischen Klimawandel gesprochen habe, das ist ja erst mal merkwürdig, spannend, aufregend, als Wissenschaftler weiß man auch nicht, was machen die, schmeißen die gleich mit Tomaten, weil die das so blöd finden oder weil man selber als so ein merkwürdiger Mensch da rüber kommt, der in der echten Welt ja gar nicht vorkommt. Von daher da macht das Spaß und ich weiß, dass es umstritten geworden ist. Also ich habe schon wieder auch gelesen in der Zeitung, manche besorgte Journalisten oder besorgte Wissenschaftler sagen, ach das ist doch nicht ordentlich, das ist ja dann nicht mehr wissenschaftlich. Und da geht es immer nur um Unterhaltung und Wissenschaft cool und witzig machen, aber Wissenschaft soll ja gar nicht cool und witzig sein. Mein Gott, also Wissenschaft kann alles sein und sie kann auch cool und witzig sein, sie ist sicherlich nicht nur cool und witzig, sondern mühselig und langwierig, aber sie kann eben auch wirklich unterhalten und deswegen verstehe ich nicht, dass da jetzt schon wieder so viele Meckerleute unterwegs sind.
Man soll doch mal ein bisschen rumspielen und ausprobieren dürfen. Und ich fände es super, wenn man auch viel mehr Räume noch erschließen könnte, um so was auszuprobieren, wie das geht.
Auch das internationale Bedenkenträgertum ist um die eigene Erhaltung natürlich bemüht. Das muss man da mit einrechnen. Aber ich denke, dass also gerade bei den Science-Slams, ich sehe es halt auch in der Podcastlandschaft auch sehr, wo ja Wissenschaftspodcasts in den letzten Jahren auch sehr stark zugenommen haben und auch insbesondere mit diesem Unterhaltungsaspekt mit reingekommen sind. Man spürt einfach etwas, was glaube ich bisher so mit Wissenschaft in der Öffentlichkeit noch nicht unbedingt verbunden ist, nämlich dieses, es macht Spaß, man kann begeistert und erfüllt davon sein. Leute, die sich gar nichts anderes vorstellen können und die einfach sich weglegen, wenn sie in irgendeinem Paper irgendeinen Fakt lesen, der erforscht wurde. Und der dann aber auch so lustig dargebracht werden kann und der dann auch über diese Brücke auch des Humors oder zumindest der unterhaltsamen Darreichung es auch schafft, so einen Brückenschlag zu machen.
Dass man sagt, das ist sowohl etwas erfüllendes, was also einen auch selber einfach glücklich macht, als auch das hat einen Wert für die Gesellschaft. Also quasi so best of both worlds so. Ich finde nicht, dass so viele Berufsbilder das so immer ohne weiteres zusammenbringen können. Und an der Stelle sind glaube ich die Slamformate, Podcastformate, in gewisser Hinsicht eben auch diese Videosachen, die ja auch dann teilweise unterhaltsam rüberkommen, schon mal ein ganz interessanter Wertewandel, der da zelebriert wird.
Genau. Ja. Also ich bin dafür, das noch weiter zu tragen und auch anders auszuprobieren und noch mutiger zu werden auch mit den verschiedenen Formaten. Wobei das mutiger werden insgesamt in der Wissenschaft wäre mir halt auch ein Anliegen. Wir müssen natürlich aufpassen, dass es nicht nur bei Unterhaltung und dem Fröhlichen bleibt, sondern dass auch mal sich wirklich streiten kann. Intellektuell streiten, also nicht mit Klopperei oder so und Brüllerei, sondern Dinge mal ausdiskutieren, die vielleicht auch wehtun, die keiner gerne anspricht, wo man eben Fronten beziehen muss. Das vermisse ich manchmal sehr in der Wissenschaft, das sich wirklich streiten können. Irgendwie muss immer alles friedlich und ordentlich und man muss geeinigt und Konsensus, aber wir haben wirklich Themen in der Wissenschaft oder auch Missverständnisse, auch über Fachgrenzen, aber auch innerhalb von Fächern hinweg, wo ein weiteres Format Wissenschaft kontrovers weiter ausgebaut werden soll, um das anzugehen, wovor alle Angst haben.
Also alle Angst über Tierversuche und den Sinn und Nutzen von Tierversuchen und Elektroden im Affengehirn zu sprechen, weil dann wird man ja bedroht heutzutage. Also es gibt Forscher, die können nicht mehr forschen und deren Kinder können nicht ohne Polizeischutz zur Schule gehen, weil sie Mittel benutzen zum Forschen, die irgendwelche Aktivisten auf den Platz holen. Und warum kann man nicht darüber diskutieren, was kann man besser machen in der Wissenschaft, wo kann man vielleicht auch aufpassen, immer wieder die ethischen Standards überprüfen, feinfühliger werden, transparenter auch werden, aber wo muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, es geht halt nicht anders und die Gesellschaft ist irgendwo bigott, wenn sie dauernd neue Medikamente haben will, älter werden will, schöner werden will, aber alles ist verboten, was die Wissenschaft tun kann, um eben diese Grenzen zu verschieben.
Da gibt es sehe ich gutes Potenzial auch mal nicht so witzige Formate, sondern aber ernsthaft gepflegter, produktiver, konstruktiver Streit, das muss ich sagen, fehlt mir insgesamt noch, dass wir da besser werden, so was zuzulassen und so was auch dann zu dokumentieren, dass es vielfältige Meinung gibt, dass nicht alles zu Konsensus führt, sondern dass es wirklich ein mühseliger Prozess des Aushandelns ist, da hätte ich Lust drauf, an so was auch mit zu arbeiten.
Klang jetzt gerade wie Beschreibung, ist aber tatsächlich der Titel eines weiteren Programms von Wissenschaft im Dialog.
Wissenschaft kontrovers.
Wissenschaft kontrovers. Ich schaue gerade mal rein hier. Diskussionsplattform und Veranstaltungsreihe. Ist das jetzt nur, hier steht im Kontext Wissenschaftsjahr 2015, ist das jetzt etwas was nur dieses Jahr stattfindet oder nur dieses Jahr unter diesem Titel steht?
Also dieses Jahr ist ja Wissenschaftsjahr. Das BMBF macht Wissenschaftsjahre mit Themen und dieses Jahr ist es ja Zukunftsstadt geworden und dann werden die Diskussionsreihen zum Beispiel auch in die Richtung dieser Thematik gestellt und dann kann es zum Beispiel Begegnungsräume geben zu, wie soll meine Stadt sein? Da ist ja auch interessant, wie Städte, die sich verändern wollen und sollen, auf einmal nichts mehr geht, weil zum Beispiel Stuttgart 21 oder so, ein Bauvorhaben die Bürger so aufregt, dass wirklich Demonstrationen Stillstand im Verkehrswegen, Polizei ist überbeschäftigt und so was haben wir ja immer wieder. Und wie kann man so was erarbeiten, wie kann man da Dialog möglich machen, dass da am Ende auch was produktives bei rauskommt. Das ist beim Thema Stadtgestaltung natürlich einfach. Weil über, wie wird der Platz vorm Hauptbahnhof gestaltet, wer darf wo lang fahren, Fahrradfahrer gegen Autofahrer, da gibt es zig Fragen.
Oder auch Energie oder auch, wie viel Grün soll es geben. Super Thema, Pflanzenallergene. Also diese Begrünung, die viele Menschen schätzen von Birken in unseren Städten, die im Sommer sehr warm werden, führt dazu, dass manche Menschen nicht mehr in der Stadt leben können, weil die so krank werden von dieser Kombination Beton und Birke, da haben wir viele Felder, in denen es Sinn macht, dass Wissenschaft und Bürger was aushandeln zusammen.
Verkehr ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Thema?
Verkehr ist ein irres Thema. Also Fahrradwege, die mitten durch eine Schnellstraße gehen, da kann man spannende Dialoge führen. Warum muss das so sein, warum kann man es nicht besser planen? Warum sind Ampelschaltungen nicht dynamischer. Kann man von der Forschungsseite bearbeiten, kann man aber auch vom Verkehrsteilnehmer, kann man aus Sicht der Polizei, aus Sicht der Architekten natürlich zusammen sprechen drüber. Und das dient auch dazu, zu sagen, wo ist Wissenschaft überall dabei. Also manchmal denken Leute, Wissenschaft ist irgendwas was ganz weit weg von ihnen ist und was mit ihrem Alltag eigentlich nichts zu tun hat. Und das ist schon auch eine Aufgabe, das zu zeigen. Also ist es so, wo heute in unserer Entwicklung, in
unserem Alltag benutzen wir eigentlich Wissenschaft, ohne groß drum zu reden und wie sehr ist oft auch diese Wissenschaft, die wir benutzen, gar nicht so ein Hightech geplantes Forschungsprojekt, sondern ein Produkt der Grundlagenforschung. Das sind so andere Sachen, die man erarbeiten kann in dem Zusammenhang.
Ein naheliegender Fokus ist ja auch noch die Jugend. Das darf natürlich nicht fehlen. Fehlt hier auch nicht. Es gibt verschiedene Programme, die sich jetzt explizit an Schüler und Jugendliche richten bei Wissenschaft im Dialog. Ich meine, dieses Hack your City, was wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben, schließt das jetzt nicht unbedingt aus, aber es gibt jetzt auch noch explizit Sachen, die sich jetzt nochmal an die Jugend wenden. Da gibt es zwei Sachen, die mir ins Auge fallen. Jugend präsentiert und ein Science Café, was gibt es dazu zu sagen? Was findet da statt?
Genau also ich bin selber auch noch ein bisschen am Lernen, ich habe noch nicht alle Produkte, die wir haben, jetzt selber schon mitgemacht. Jugend präsentiert war ich schon dabei. Das kann man sich so ein bisschen jetzt mal überspitzt wie Deutschland sucht den Superstar, aber eben für Wissenschaftspräsentationen. Da bewerben sich Kinder, die Lust darauf haben und haben eine bestimmte Idee zu einem Thema, oft wird so ein Thema ausgeschrieben zum Beispiel Luft. Und dann machen die Kinder – die können glaube ich so im Alter von 12-18 oder so was – können dann sich ein Projekt erarbeiten, der Lehrer hilft dann vor Ort. Also es beteiligen sich Schulen und die fangen dann an, erst mal darüber nachzudenken, was will ich eigentlich mitteilen und dann lernen die selber, vielleicht forschen die auch ein bisschen was, haben eine Frage. Der letzte Gewinner zum Beispiel bei Jugend präsentiert, der hat Klarinette gespielt und wollte jetzt mal wissen, wie funktioniert das eigentlich ganz genau, dass ich eben mit der Klarinette Töne machen kann und das da Musik am Ende des Tages rauskommt, was ist die Physik dahinter.
Oder ein anderes Kind wollte wissen, warum fliegen Flugzeuge, die sehen so aus als müssten sie nach unten fallen, aber was genau ist der Trick beim Flugzeug und was muss ich da am Design eigentlich wissen, um zu wissen, ist das ein gutes Flugzeug. Und so gibt es Fragen eben aus dem Alltag, was Kinder sich erarbeiten können. Und wenn die erst mal an ihrer Schule soweit kommen, können die vorgeschlagen werden für den Wettbewerb. Gehen dann auch in so ein Trainingscamp und dann wird so wettbewerblich ermittelt immer, wer kommt so ein Stück weiter in den Runden und am Ende ist der Wettbewerb für ganz Deutschland und da sitzen dann die Kinder, die eben dann ihre Vorträge zeigen und sich einer Jury stellen und dann auch immer ein Feedback kriegen zu ihrem Vortrag und da wird dann ein Gewinner und ein 2. und 3. Platz gelost und das ist dann aufregend für die Kinder. Aber auch fürs Panel, weil wenn man erst mal die sieht, die so in der Endausscheidung der letzten 10 Projekte ist, die will man schon sofort immer als Doktoranden einstellen, weil die so irre gut was erzählen können.
Zuerst war ich sehr kritisch, weil ich eben dieses ganze, Kinder müssen schon gleich auf die Bühne, Kinder müssen sich dem Wettbewerb stellen, Kinder müssen bewertet werden, vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass ich selber als Kind so ein graues Entlein war, dass ich das auch einen wahnsinnigen Druck finde. Oder auch habe ich gedacht, oh Gott und die Armen und dann sind das so Nerds, die keiner mag, die gemobbt werden, die haben dann halt einmal so ein Highlight, in dem sie dann mal was sagen dürfen. Aber so ist es überhaupt nicht. Das sind völlig begeisterte kreative Kinder, die einfach selber drüber nachdenken, wie kann ich was sagen, so dass man mir zuhört, dass ich was transportieren kann. Da ist kein Unterschied zwischen Kind und Erwachsener da mehr. Und das macht echt Spaß, denen zuzugucken. Also mir stand der Mund offen, als ich da saß und dann diese Präsentationen gehört habe. Wie liebevoll die erarbeitet waren. Aber auch wie anders dann Kinder über Sachen reden können.
Da war eine Gruppe von Jungs, die haben über den Tod gesprochen. Also was ist die Biochemie des Todes und haben das in ihrer Jugendsprache, aber eben super gut biochemisch aufgebaut, aber dann doch so ganz emotionslos über Sterben und Vergammeln gesprochen. Das war auch sehr spannend. Also ich kann nur empfehlen, wenn so was in der Stadt ist, da mal hinzugehen und sich das anzugucken, weil naja was ist Kind, was ist ein Erwachsener, und können nicht Erwachsene manchmal Kinder sein und Kinder manchmal Erwachsene ist sowieso interessant. Und da kommt es toll raus, wie sehr Kinder, wenn man sie mitnimmt, wenn sie kreativ sein können, aber auch warum so ein bisschen Wettbewerb gar nicht so schlecht ist auch für ein Kind, um angefeuert zu werden, um auch eine Rückmeldung zu kriegen. Was habe ich zu sagen und glaubt mir einer? Kann ich es besser machen? Das ist schon toll.
Findet dann die Präsentation auch vor Publikum statt oder?
Ja total. Da kommen dann die Schulklassen mit. Also die haben dann alle kleine Fanclubs und dann sind da auch Wissenschaftler, Lehrer, das Panel ist bunt zusammengesetzt, Journalisten sind meistens auch dabei. Das ist ein voller Raum. Und das Publikum selber wählt mit und das Panel wählt mit und so nähert man sich an und kriegt dann raus, wer kann es halt besonders gut.
Ich hörte gerade raus, also es geht jetzt hier nicht nur so um, jetzt kommt mal her präsentiert mal und wir bewerten das dann, sondern es wird auch Unterstützung gegeben?
Absolut.
Also Trainingscamps habe ich jetzt raus gehört, also es wird sozusagen in dem Moment, wo man daran teilnimmt, wird auch das Vermitteln von Informationen begleitet?
Ja genau. Und da haben die Lehrer was davon, aber auch die Kinder. Also zum Beispiel PowerPoint-Präsentationen, kann ja grauenvoll sein, aber wenn man es richtig macht, unterstützt es sehr die Kommunikation und die kriegen dann beigebracht, mit PowerPoint zu arbeiten. Und wenn man dann mal so 12-Jährige sieht, die mit einem iPad und alle diese Medien eben professionell nutzt, um zu erklären, warum ein Flugzeug fliegt, das ist schon beeindruckend. Da hat man das Gefühl, Mensch so könnte es auch gehen, dass Kinder auch viel mehr beteiligt werden. Weil sie es so können, weil sie mit den Geräten natürlich umgehen, das Lernen ist da eigentlich das Hauptziel daran. Und das Interessieren für Naturwissenschaft. Wir haben ja weiter ein irres Problem, vor allen Dingen Mädchen für MINT-Wissenschaften, also Mathematik, Naturwissenschaft, Ingenieurswesen, da ist es ja weiterhin traurig, ganz wenige Mädchen haben Lust, sich dem Ingenieurswesen oder dem Maschinenbau oder der Technikwissenschaft zu stellen.
Und da ist auch Effekt dabei, bei diesem Wettbewerb. Da sind Mädchen wie Jungs dabei und man das befördern auch durch so etwas. Und es hat doch große Breitenwirkung. Am Ende gibt es nur ein paar Preisträger, aber das ist ganz groß aufgestellt in den Schulen die Beteiligung. Also das bringt auf jeden Fall was und da musste ich auch umdenken, diese ganze Geschichte mit Preisen und Medaillen und so, da habe ich manchmal finde ich, warum muss das sein. Aber ja weil der Anreiz daran, auf so ein Ziel hinzuarbeiten, das tut nicht nur weh, wenn man nicht gewinnt, sondern das befördert auch irgendwie den sportlichen fröhlichen Wettbewerb um was und das geht besser, wenn es am Ende halt so ein Ziel eines Preises, einer Medaille, als wenn alle nur jeder macht was und dann gehen alle wieder auseinander. Das ist so unverbindlich, aber dieses hin zu sich dem Wettbewerb stellen ist eigentlich auch gut, früh trainiert zu werden.
Ich würde da gerne nochmal nachfragen. Der Grund oder die Gründe, dass Mädchen sich den MINT-Wissenschaften sich noch nicht so zuwenden oder nicht wieder so zuwenden, das war ja auch schon mal anders?
Das ist noch nie so richtig toll geworden, auch wenn Jungs und Mädchen heute halbe halbe Doktorarbeit machen, also genauso viele Mädchen wie Jungs werden Doktor, sind aber die Fächer, die ausgewählt werden, um darin zu arbeiten, völlig verschoben. Und in den Ingenieurswissenschaften, in der Physik, in der Mathematik bleibt es bei kümmerlichen 15%. Also es gibt immer mal Arbeitsgruppen oder Universitäten, die schaffen es besser, aber im Durchschnitt ist das erbärmlich. Also Frauen gestalten nicht die Technikwissenschaften heutzutage, immer noch nicht. Und man kann was da heute ran rückt an Kindern, die ja später mal unsere Ingenieure von Deutschland sind, wenn der große Fachkräftemangel kommt, das wird heute schwer immer noch. Also die Frau als Möglichkeit in diesen Mangel da reinzugrätschen, da muss man sich anstrengen. Und es werden viele Gründe vermutet, hat was mit mangelnden Rollenbildern natürlich zu tun.
Also wenn man den Fernseher anschaltet ist es auch nicht, dass die Frau einem als Ingenieur entgegen springt, das spielt eine Rolle. Auch im Film, im Fernsehen, in der Kultur gibt es sehr verstärkte, verfestigte Rollenbilder. Es gibt natürlich aber auch die Art und Weise, wie ein Studium diese Fächer sich selber darstellen, die manchmal abschreckend sind, also wenn zum Beispiel Ingenieurswissenschaft wieder mit irgendwas für die Umwelt oder irgendwas für die Tiere oder irgendwas für die Medizin verknüpft wird, kriegt man ganz schnell viel mehr Frauen in einen Studiengang, als wenn es nur heißt, Maschinenbau. Also da gibt es Möglichkeiten, nachzusteuern. Aber es bleibt eben dabei, dass auch schon in der Schule, wie schafft man das da eben, Interesse zu wecken. Ein immer noch umstrittenes Feld ist, sollen Mädchen und Jungs in der Schule getrennten Mathematik-, Physikunterricht haben, denn sie können für sich genommen in einer schwierigen Zeit vielleicht doch besser lernen oder anders die Fächer erschließen als zusammen, wo sie im Wettbewerb dann irgendwo auch zueinander stehen.
Da wird viel drüber nachgedacht. Also es sind viele Faktoren, die zusammenkommen, aber auf jeden Fall kommt raus, wir können es uns eigentlich nicht leisten, dass das immer so weitergeht, dass da nicht noch mehr aufgebaut wird, noch mehr geworben wird, mehr rein geholt wird an weiblicher Kompetenz für die Frage der Zukunft unserer Technik.
Ist das auch Fokus jetzt für WiD?
Wir haben wenig so ganz direkten Genderfokus, aber unsere Formate unterstützen, die denken halt mit, da gibt es eben mehrere wie gesagt, die gut klappen, wie bei Jugend präsentiert. Als ich da mir das angehört habe, da habe ich gesehen, Mann da sind genauso viele Mädchen, die erzählen nicht Luft und Flöte, sondern Luft und Flugzeug oder Luft und ein bestimmtes, - was war das, was hat die eine gemacht – Kompressor oder Motor oder so. Die haben aber auch eben sich auf die Bühne stellen, was darstellen, ein kleiner Star sein, vielleicht da auch einen anderen Zugangsweg als im normalen Physik- oder Mathematikunterricht an der Schule. Also so Kombinationen von Kompetenzen, die scheinen da eine wichtige Rolle zu spielen und da bringt es glaube ich schon was, was wir da machen.
Ein zweites Projekt ist das Junior Science Café, was sich auch nochmal hier speziell den Jugendlichen andient. Was steckt dahinter?
Das habe ich noch nicht mitgemacht. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein Begegnungsraum auch zwischen Jugendlichen und Wissenschaftlern, also Erwachsenen, eben um gemeinsam auch über Fragen der Zukunft, über Projekte, über Forschung zu sprechen. Wir haben das ja natürlich schon länger, dass Forscher – und das macht glaube ich jedes Forschungsinstitut oder an jeder Uni gibt es Kinderunis oder man geht raus und trifft Kinder an der Schule, arbeitet mit denen an der Schule – das ist spannend, weil diese direkte Neugierde, die Kinder ja erst mal haben, die einem in der Pubertät leider durch Hormonumstellung erst mal verloren geht oder oft, das ist interessant wie Kinder Fragen stellen, wie die an Wissen herangehen, wie bei denen Neugierde vorherrscht. Und unabhängig vom WiD habe ich das selber auch schon ein paar Mal ausprobiert, Kinderuni oder Kinder im Schulunterricht.
Das schätze ich als Wissenschaftler, weil eben diese direkten Fragen nicht gefiltert durch irgendwie erlerntes einem weiterhelfen, auch die Wissenschaft anders aufzustellen. Also zum Beispiel wenn ich mit meinen Tiefseefischen da ankomme, dann wollen die Kinder wissen, warum ist der Fisch so hässlich. Das ist ja erst mal keine wissenschaftliche Frage hässlich und schön, aber wenn man darüber nachdenkt, was meinen die eigentlich mit hässlich, und dann habe ich versucht zu erklären, warum sieht denn der so aus, mit dem riesen Maul und den Zähnen und den Haaren. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, die haben mich jetzt gezwungen, mich wirklich also mit der Morphologie von den Fischen zu beschäftigen und die wiederum waren erstaunt und haben gelernt, hässlich ist eigentlich kein feststehender Begriff, sondern hier ist der Fisch doch eigentlich schön, weil der so toll angepasst ist. Also Anpassung ist schön und Erfolg und so weiter. Und da kamen wir in einen echt wirklich guten Dialog zusammen und die Kinder waren halt 7-8 Jahre alt und ich bin 47 und wir haben uns aber ernsthaft für zwei Stunden über die Fragen, was ist hässlich, was ist schön, was ist Anpassung unterhalten und ich hatte danach das Gefühl, hier nicht nur als Lehrer oder Zeitverschwendung oder was, ich hatte das Gefühl von einem ernsthaften intellektuellen Dialog und das zum Beispiel ist etwas, was man bei diesen Junior Science Cafés eben pflegen kann.
Ja ich denke bei Jugendlichen fehlt auch einfach häufig so ein bisschen die Bereitschaft, die einfach so zu nehmen wie sie sind und einfach auch ernst zu nehmen.
Ja umgekehrt müssen Jugendliche auch vergessen, dass Erwachsene irgendwie merkwürdig und doof und ganz anders interessiert sind. Wenn Jugendliche mit Wissenschaftlern sprechen stellen die manchmal fest, die sind irgendwie auch Kinder. Die haben irgendwie nur eins Kopf oder antworten ganz anders als ich es vielleicht kenne von meinem Papa, der von der Bank gekommen ist oder so. Ja es geht eben um Kommunikation und mal mit denen zu reden, mit denen man normal nicht redet ist eigentlich immer gut.
Das stimmt. Ein ganz anderer Fokus ist ein Projekt das heißt Science Starter. Da geht es um Geld. Das ist ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig bei der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit, Finanzierung zu finden für die eigene Tätigkeit. Mag manchen gelingen im Rahmen von einer Beschäftigung oder Projekten an Universitäten. Aber häufig hat man ja halt auch einfach eine Idee, die man gerne realisieren würde, wo sich eben nicht gerade irgendein Förderpreis findet oder irgendein Programm eines Bundesministeriums oder wo hier an der Uni was übrig ist. Science Starter ist auch vom WiD gestartet worden das Projekt ursprünglich? Ich habe es so in Erinnerung. Ist auf jeden Fall da angesiedelt jetzt.
Kann gut sein. Also auf jeden Fall ist es angesiedelt, wird begleitet. Es gibt einen Projektleiter, der das verfolgt und auch dort kann man eben sein Projekt anbieten und kann Leute finden über die Plattform, die dort von Wissenschaft und Dialog betrieben wird. Forschung Wissenschaft zu bezahlen. Diese Idee des Crowdfundings gibt es ja schon viel länger. Das hat nicht WiD erfunden, das wird vor allen Dingen, also bisher kannte ich es eher aus den Formaten Kunst, Musik, ja Leute aber auch Gesundheit, also in Amerika, wo es ein kleines Gesundheitssystem gibt, gibt es Crowdfunding für Krankheiten, für Menschen, die Schicksale haben, denen geholfen werden muss.
Aber vor allem halt im Produktbereich war es ja sehr erfolgreich von Anfang mit Kickstarter, hier ich möchte gern dieses Produkt.
Genau die Kickstarter ja genau. Und für die Wissenschaft ist es halt sehr umstritten, weil Wissenschaft ist ja wie Bildung in Deutschland vom Steuerzahler eh finanziert. Und der Frage, wer kriegt von wem Geld hat auch was mit Qualität zu tun, weil ja eigentlich die, die Geld kriegen, sollen ja theoretisch die sein, die also das beste Forschungsprojekt haben, die einen Standard haben, die eine Vorarbeit haben usw. Jetzt wenn man mit Crowdfunding bei Wissenschaft losmacht, dann ist auch sofort die Frage, wer darf in diesen Wettbewerbsraum rein. Es wäre ja schön, wenn es jetzt für die Studenten mit super kreativen Ideen wäre, aber was, wenn dann ein Helmholtzinstitut da reingeht und irgendwie was tolles verspricht und auf einmal fangen die Leute an, halt da zu bezahlen und nicht den kleinen Studenten. Also dieses, wer darf wen funden und was soll das und was macht das mit der Wissenschaft, da wird auch wirklich viel gestritten um dieses Projekt.
Aber ist denn überhaupt schon so viel passiert dadurch, dass man jetzt sagen kann, das hat schon nennenswerte Auswirkungen?
Okay, also nennenswerte Auswirkungen aufs Wissenschaftssystem als solches nicht, aber für diese Frage, kann es in Zukunft. Also in der Musik hat es ja eine erhebliche Wirkung. Also bei Bands oder bei manchen Leuten, die sich über Kunst Geld verdienen, die leben nur noch von so was.
Aber ich denke im Kunstbereich oder im Musik oder Unterhaltungsbereich, da ist es natürlich ein bisschen was anderes. Weil da einfach das Verhältnis Fan und Produzent auch eine ganz anders emotionale Bindung einfach vorherrscht. Und auch bei Produkten ist es so ein bisschen, dass Menschen schnell so zu bestimmten Geräten und so, wir kennen das ja alles mit unseren Gadgets und Devices, dass man da einfach so eine Affinität aufbaut, die eben auch eine hohe Zahlungsbereitschaft mit sich bringt. Insbesondere wenn die eigentlichen geforderten Beträge überschaubar sind, also sowohl jetzt was die Endsumme betrifft, als auch das, was man halt mindestens geben muss, weil man kommt ja da mit wenig hin. Wissenschaft, das ist natürlich jetzt eine interessante Frage, was ist so da die, was ist so das Versprechen, was man geben kann, wenn man selber mit Crowdfunding daherkommt und an wen wendet man sich? Wer ist quasi jetzt hier das Publikum? Ich meine, es gibt ja durchaus Mäzene, es gibt Leute, die Geld haben und das gerne umgesetzt wissen möchten.
Manche gehen dann halt in Stiftungen, wenn es so viel Geld ist, dass sich das auch schon lohnt oder man kombiniert es eben mit anderen. Das ist ja auch ein Tätigkeitsfeld für den Stifterverband, aber hier muss man eben gar nicht erst soweit gehen. Hier kann man eben sagen, ach ja das wäre doch mal interessant, wenn das mal verfolgt wird, ich kann das vielleicht auch selber beurteilen, dass das jetzt eine relevante Tätigkeit ist, warum soll ich denn da jetzt nicht nochmal 10 Euro drauf schmeißen.
Ja genau. Aber eben die Frage des, sich Kaufens von Wissenschaft, da muss man sich ja schon Gedanken drüber machen. Wie gesagt, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, erst mal finde ich es auch super, dass alles ausprobiert wird und dann wird jetzt mal geguckt, klappt das zum Beispiel für Bereiche von Wissenschaft zum Beispiel ein Buch schreiben. Also ein Forschungsthema haben in der Geisteswissenschaft und am Ende soll ein Buch rauskommen. Da ist es tatsächlich so, weil auch gerade dort oft Leute, die eine Doktorarbeit machen, kaum überhaupt die Mittel zum Leben haben oder vielleicht einen Einjahresvertrag gestreckt auf drei Jahre haben oder so. Die können sagen, ich forsche jetzt hier und ich möchte gern dies erforschen und darüber schreibe ich dann ein Buch und das habt ihr mir finanziert. So was ist doch eigentlich eine super Idee, wenn das so geht. Was ist aber, wenn man jetzt anfängt, ein Thema zu kaufen. Also ein Thema in Auftrag zu geben oder Einfluss nehmen zu wollen. Das ist schon diese Frage, wer bezahlt Wissenschaft, die ist eine, die man sich in vielen Bereichen stellen muss.
Aber hier wiederum ist es einfach erst mal ein Experiment, klappt es überhaupt? Beteiligen sich da Leute? Wie viel Geld fließt dann? Die meisten Projekte sind glaube ich zwischen 1000-10000 Euro jetzt angesiedelt. Aber es gibt auch glaube ich schon ein paar, die drüber rausgehen. Macht es zum Beispiel Sinn, wenn sich da einer hinstellt, ich mache Biodiversitätsforschung, will die Käfervielfalt von Berlin studieren und ihr kauft mir jetzt die Kameraausrüstung durch euer Geld. Ist das was was anständig ist oder müsste eigentlich, wenn diese Forschung wichtig ist und richtig ist, nicht doch das an einem Forschungsinstitut angesiedelt sein, was natürlich ein leichtes hat, eine Kamera zu kaufen.
Anständig von wem? Von der Gesellschaft anständig oder von dem Forscher?
Beides. Also wie gesagt, der wer Projektförderung bekommt, der ist durch einen Peer-Reviewing-Prozess gelaufen, wo die Qualität der Forschung überprüft wird. Und wir haben unsere Wissenschaft und die Ehrlichkeit und Transparenz oder das Gefüge unserer Wissenschaft beruht auch darauf, dass wir uns immer dieser Prüfung unterziehen. Ich sage das jetzt mal so. Ich glaube da nicht zu 100% dran, weil was durch diese fördern nach Bewahrung im System gefördert wird, lässt oft mal ganz kreative verrückte Ideen beiseite, weil da hat einer eine Idee, hat aber noch nichts dazu jemals geleistet oder ausprobiert, der kriegt so leicht kein Geld für seine Forschung, wenn er nicht schon bewiesen hat, ich bin da super gut drin. Also in dem Bereich, sagen wir mal, kleinere Ideen flexibel und schnell umzusetzen, sich was zu trauen, wo man nur eine Idee hat, aber keine Vorarbeit, für so was wäre das gut, man muss es aber im Auge behalten. Weil es reibt schon an einigen Punkten, was Wissenschaft eigentlich sein will und ich bin gespannt darauf, wie sich das weiter entwickelt.
Da möchte ich gerne nochmal ein bisschen drauf eingehen, weil ich finde so diesen Begriff des Kaufens, ich meine, wer genug Geld hat, sich Wissenschaft zu kaufen, und sich was kaufen will, der kann das ja heutzutage problemlos tun, da ist man dann eine Firma und macht sich halt einfach seinen eigenen Forschungsbereich und stellt sich die Wissenschaftler einfach an. Ich meine, das macht ja jedes große Unternehmen.
Aber das ist ja eben keine Forschung, das ist dann Industrieforschung, die ist ja nicht Forschung, die im Wissenschaftsraum sozusagen ist.
Aber jemand will das und kauft sich das ja sozusagen. Also ist ja in dem Sinne nichts anderes. Also wenn ich mir jetzt die Käferstruktur in Berlin, wenn das für mich jetzt einfach interessant ist und ich will mir das kaufen, dann kann ich das ja machen, dann finde ich jetzt nicht verwerflicher das zu tun, als wenn ich irgendein Business mir erträume und mir da die passendes Forscher zu einkaufe. Da sehe ich jetzt den Unterschied nicht so richtig.
Nein, aber für alle diese Systeme gibt es ja bekannte Prozesse, wie wer was von wem kauft und bezahlt und wie dann das Wissen entsteht und wie das Wissen auch bewahrt und verbreitet wird. Wenn die Industrie Industrieforschung macht, dann muss es sich für die irgendwo lohnen, die gehen auch ein bestimmtes Risiko in manchen Bereichen ein, aber begrenzt, aber die machen jetzt nicht Forschung für die andere Firma, sondern für sich selber. Also es ist klar, dass am Ende irgendwie was ökonomisches, was wertvolles, was wertschaffendes rauskommen muss. Das weiß jeder, deswegen weiß jeder wie er diese Industrieforschung jetzt einordnen und beurteilen soll. Wenn eine Uni forscht, dann ist es klar, dass da vorher bestimmte Prozesse durchlaufen worden sind, wo über ein wettbewerbliches Verfahren im Grunde ein bestimmter Qualitätszustand erst mal ermittelt wurde. Wenn jetzt aber irgendwelche Menschen über die Science Starter Plattform ein Projekt anbieten und irgendwelche anderen Menschen da irgendwie Geld rein zahlen, ist es noch ein unklarer, ungefestigter Raum, wer hier Forschung in Auftrag gibt, bezahlt, wer für wen forscht.
Ist das überhaupt ein ernsthafter Forscher oder hat der ein Qualitätskriterium, all diese Sachen sind in freiem Raum.
Aber am Ende entscheidet doch das Ergebnis.
Nein.
Weil ja das Ergebnis wiederum eine Methode braucht, die überprüfbar sein muss, damit man wissen kann, es ist gesichertes Wissen.
Warum nicht?
Ja aber das kann man doch im Nachgang dann auch überprüfen. Ich meine in dem Moment, wo das Ergebnis da ist, dann wird es ja dann auch peerreviewed, sonst würde es ja auch überhaupt gar keinen Anklang finden. Also wenn dann nur das Ergebnis als solches jetzt im Raum steht.
Da sind wir ganz am Anfang eben, da muss man hingucken. Also zum Beispiel klar wie gesagt, wenn jetzt eben so ein Modell wie, jemand hat eine bestimmte Frage, will ein Buch darüber schreiben und dann hat man am Ende das Buch und das Buch ist auf dem Markt und dann wird sich schon zeigen, ist das Buch für irgendwas gut oder nicht. Aber in bestimmten anderen Bereichen der Forschung ist es unklar, was nützt es oder ist es in Ordnung, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ich gehe jetzt und erforsche, wie Katzen auf Straßenlärm reagieren und setze mich hin und beobachte ein paar Katzen und schreibe dann hinterher eine Veröffentlichung über die Katzen. Kann der das überhaupt veröffentlichen, wenn das eben außerhalb des normalen Wissenschaftsbereiches gelaufen ist die Untersuchung? Ist der angebunden als Wissenschaftler? All diese Fragen sind noch echt ungeklärt.
Ja muss man das sein unbedingt? Also ich sehe so die Probleme noch nicht. Und sehe, naja gut, vielleicht mein mir innewohnender Optimismus, weil ich auch so ein bisschen selbst auch so ein bisschen aus einer nichtwissenschaftlichen Umfeld komme, wo ich gesehen habe, dass Leute einfach so mit einem, ach ich mach jetzt einfach mal Ansatz zu hervorragenden Ergebnissen kommen. Und ich glaube ja auch, dass niemand, der jetzt sich selber als Wissenschaftler versteht und jetzt an so eine Öffentlichkeit ran geht, die ja auch keine beliebige Öffentlichkeit ist, ich meine, wer wendet sich denn bitte einer Wissenschaftscrowdfunding-Plattform zu. Klar, das eine Attribut ist, hat vielleicht Geld über, aber das andere ist ja auch, hat Interesse und ist in gewisser Hinsicht wahrscheinlich auch sowieso schon Teil des wissenschaftlichen Systems in irgendeiner Form.
Und diese Kombination findet man jetzt nicht irgendwo, sondern man hat es an der Stelle wahrscheinlich, vielleicht entspricht es jetzt nicht diesem wissenschaftlichen Peerreview-Qualitäten an sich, aber da ist schon auch eine Art Review, der schon stattfindet. Weil bevor ich jetzt da mit einem wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund, den ich jetzt so nicht habe, aber den ich in dem Fall vielleicht haben könnte, dahingehe und sage, okay, wo werfe ich denn jetzt mal die 100 Euro drauf, die ich bereit bin, jeden Monat hier in irgendetwas zu investieren, da schaue ich mir das natürlich dann mit vergleichbaren – das unterstelle ich jetzt mal – mit vergleichbaren Kriterien an.
Nein, gar nicht. Sie würden ja jetzt, weil das ist ja gerade der Unterschied zwischen dem wissenschaftlichen Raum und dem gesellschaftlichen, dass Sie jetzt gar nicht wissen, haben schon 100 Leute diesen Versuch vorher gemacht? Oder Sie wissen auch nicht, ist der überhaupt auf dem Kontext des schon erhobenen Wissens aufgebaut? Oder Sie wissen auch nicht, Sie würden nichts bezahlen wollen, was komplett konträr zu Ihrer eigenen Meinung ist, sondern Sie finden das gut, wo Sie sich wiederfinden, wo Sie das Gefühl haben, ach das verstehe ich, das finde ich super, da will ich mein Geld hinsetzen. Und das ist das, also nicht ich will jetzt auf keinen Fall unser Superexperiment Science Starter kleinreden, aber es schürft ??? Wissen an dem Feedback, was wir dazu kriegen, dass es die Gemüter anheizt, weil im großen Stil passiert in anderen Ländern genau das, dass die Gesellschaft sozusagen in diesen Reviewing Prozess, wo das Geld hin eingebunden wird und dadurch wird Wissenschaft verändert.
Wenn nur noch das, was der Meinung der Gesellschaft entspricht ausgewählt wird, wenn die Gesellschaft selber bestimmt, was ist das nächste große Forschungsprojekt, wo soll mein Steuergeld hin. Dafür gibt es Ansatzpunkte in anderen Ländern, dass so was immer mehr passiert. Dann wird die Wissenschaft insgesamt schlechter. Und jetzt muss man wieder bei Wissenschaft im Dialog ja sagen, wir schaffen hier diese tollen Experimentierräume, aber es ist die Wissenschaft, die in gewisser Weise ihr Geld da rein gibt und hofft, dass Wissenskommunikation besser wird und da schaffen wir ja natürlich auch Konflikte, aber das ist ja auch gut. Wir wollen uns ja auch ein bisschen darum streiten, was ist gute Wissenschaftskommunikation, was sind gute Projekte. Und mein Gefühl ist, dass von allen Projekten, die wir haben, dieses Crowdfunding bestimmt eines wie Citizen Science generell so eher ein Konfliktthema ist, weil es auch ganz neu ist, weil man noch gar nicht weiß, was draus wird und läuft das überhaupt. Deswegen muss man da hinschauen, aber ja ich frage mich diese Fragen eben auch, was bedeutet das eigentlich, was fördern wir da am Ende des Tages, was hat das für einen Rückhalt?
Vielleicht ist es ja auch nur ein interessantes – ich meine, so wie es jetzt sich hier präsentiert mit dem Science Starter kopiert es ja mehr oder weniger das Kickstarter-Modell.
Klar.
Das heißt man hat jetzt erst mal etwas genommen, was im anderen Produktbereich etc. Ganz gut funktioniert. Übrigens ja auch teilweise im journalistischen Bereich auch schon.
Echt kann man Journalisten auch über Crowd?
Ja.
Echt ah? Das wusste ich nicht.
Ja gibt es auch. Ja Deutschland, besonders hier Korrektiv, diese neue Gruppe von Journalisten, die sich zusammen getan hat, die haben auch eine eigene Plattform jetzt aufgesetzt, über die verschiedene journalistische Recherchemaßnahmen finanziert werden. Habe ich mich auch schon dran beteiligt, fand ich wirklich super. Weil man auch dadurch überhaupt mal auf Themen auch aufmerksam wird. Ein ganz anderes Interesse dann auch auf einmal daran entwickelt. Also es ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch etwas, mit dem man auch so eine Community aufbaut. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt quasi so zwei totale Extreme. Also das sind jetzt hier so ein bisschen so die beiden Bilder. Also auf der einen Seite so, hat eigentlich keine Ahnung von Wissenschaft, aber Geld über und finanziert da jetzt mal und macht so aus der Sicht der Anderen da vielleicht irgendwie alles kaputt.
Und das andere Extrem ist so, der wissenschaftliche Apparat mit seinen Förderstrukturen, wie es bisher immer so war, der nichts anderes kennt als, nur das was uns jetzt mal total in den Kram passt, und wo wir uns auch alles angeschaut habe, kriegt dann was und dann zwar aber auch alles. Ja also dann wird da sozusagen das Projekt wird dann entweder vollkommen finanziert oder gar nicht. Vielleicht kann man das ja auch irgendwann mal auflösen in so ein Modell, wo Wissenschaftler schon diesem Peerreview sich unterziehen, aber vielleicht von verschiedenen Teilen, dass sozusagen verschiedene Fördertöpfe sagen, naja wir finanzieren nicht das ganze Projekt, aber auch wir schmeißen da jetzt nochmal 500 Euro rein.
Das geht gar nicht. Das ist das grausigste für einen Wissenschaftler, der seine Projekte, die er aufgeschrieben hat. Ja okay, jetzt gibt es halt nur die Hälfte der Mittel, weil dann geht nichts von der Idee. Grausig.
Nein, nein. Es gilt ja nach wie vor dieses hopp oder topp, also man definiert ja selber, das brauche ich. Nur kommt es vielleicht aus mehr als einer Quelle.
Ja klar, das ist ja im echten Leben eh so. Also das müssen wir eh so zusammengestoppelt unsere Mittel einholen. Das stimmt auf jeden Fall. Aber ja die Experimentierfreudigkeit, die Risikofreudigkeit in der Wissenschaft zu fördern, auf Projekte zu setzen, wo man nur eine Idee hat, sonst nichts, das ist sowieso in der Wissenschaft ein Thema, da werden auch weiterhin Formate entwickelt, meistens geht es über Preisgelder. Es gibt aber auch wirklich echte, auch bei der EU, Ideenförderprojekte in der Wissenschaft selber, aber meist ist dann zumindest klar, was für ein Wissenschaftler ist das, der sich da stellt. Und hier ist es noch bunter und deswegen gucken wir dahin und sind gespannt, wie das wächst und wie viel Geld da am Ende des Tages rein fließt, wie viele Leute sich daran beteiligen. Ich glaube wir müssen auch unbedingt nochmal hinschauen, ob es nicht nur Omi und Opi sind, die dann ihr Patenkind fördern. Das war nur ein Witz. Das kenne ich von einer Künstler Science Starter Plattform, dass das dann doch zum Teil halt hauptsächlich die Familie des Künstlers ist.
Naja aber immerhin auch ein Transportweg, dass dann vielleicht etwas unverbindlicher zu machen, als es sonst dann wäre.
Aber auch eine super, das hat eben auch eine sehr gute Suchfunktion. Man kann es sich einfach mal anschauen, rauskriegen, was gibt es alles, in welchen Bereichen gibt es das. Also interessant ist auch überhaupt was rauszukriegen, dadurch dass es das jetzt gibt, kriegt man einfach raus, welche Projekte laufen denn überhaupt.
Wofür interessieren sich denn diese Wissenschaftler überhaupt. Was würden sie denn gerne machen. Und was ich hier auch gerade dem Blog noch entnehme, was natürlich ganz gut zu dem passt, was wir vorhin schon besprochen haben, die Idee der Bürgerwissenschaften sozusagen, an der Stelle ja Leute, die sozusagen sonst gar keine Möglichkeit hätten, sich so ein Funding zu holen, da sie eben diesen Peerreview-Kriterien niemals entsprechen würden, die könnten hier vielleicht mit der Plattform noch sehr viel mehr anfangen. Also das ist ein interessantes Spannungsfeld, wie man so schön sagt.
Ja auf jeden Fall.
Wo man auch schon so sieht, wie das so am Gesamtsystem auch reißt und dran zerrt. Ja gut so, wenn das so ist. Ja jetzt haben wir schon eine ganze Menge besprochen. Gibt es denn noch irgendein Projekt oder Aspekt von Wissenschaft im Dialog, den wir jetzt noch so gar nicht behandelt haben, der es vielleicht noch wert wäre, erwähnt zu werden?
Ja ich würde da nochmal das Wissenschaftsbarometer erwähnen. Und zwar in all diesen Bemühungen, die Kommunikation, also den Transport von Wissenschaft zu ganz verschiedenen Empfängern, zu ganz verschiedenen Zielgruppen, aber auch eben die Interaktion, also auch das Rückholen von Fragen, von Wissen, von Ideen, von Bewertungen, da müssen wir uns natürlich insgesamt fragen, was bringt das jetzt alles? Also es waren grad ein paar auch sehr aggressive Artikel Spiegel Online, wo drin stand, ist doch alles Quatsch. Keiner kennt Wissenschaft im Dialog. Was bringt das? Also die Wissenschaftler machen sich lächerlich oder die besetzen das Feld der Wissenschaftsjournalisten und es gibt bald keine Wissenschaftsjournalisten, weil die Wissenschaft denen die Kommunikation wegnehmen oder was sind da alles für – es sind viele Artikel oder viele so Selbstbeschäftigungsmomente jetzt, was bringt das, für was ist das gut?
Und es ist ein wichtiges Thema, zu fragen, bei der Aktivität, die gemessen zu dem, was zum Beispiel in den USA los ist oder in England los ist, ist es minimal, was wir in Deutschland ausgeben für dieses Thema Wissenschaftskommunikation. Also man könnte sagen, wir sind ganz am Anfang, wir müssen noch viel mehr machen. Auf der anderen Seite müssen wir auch hingucken, was kommt raus, was bringt das? Und das tut natürlich die immer geldlimitierte Wissenschaft auch. Und da ist ein Verfahren, was ganz interessant ist, das Wissenschaftsbarometer. Das ist sehr übergreifend stellt es einfach Fragen an Bürger, was denken Sie zu meinetwegen Kernforschung? Oder was und dann kommen so ein Möglichkeiten. Dann kommt als Frage, fühlen Sie sich von der Wissenschaft gut beraten? Finden Sie die Wissenschaft ist fehlgesteuert? Glauben Sie Wissenschaftlern mehr als Politikern, Ihrem Pfarrer usw.?
Also es sind so verschiedene Fragen an Bürger, eine Umfragesituation. Und zusammengenommen kann man die auswerten professionell und kriegt dann eine Art Abbild dessen, wie die Gesellschaft über Wissenschaft denk. Über bestimmte Themen der Wissenschaft denkt, über Aufgaben der Wissenschaft denkt und das ist ganz weit voneinander weg, diese einzelnen Formate, die wir heute besprochen haben und dieses Gesamtgefühl der Gesellschaft, was bringt uns Wissenschaft. Aber beides zusammen sind so Endmember???, indem man rauskriegt, was tun wir eigentlich und wo müssen wir hin? In Deutschland stehen wir irre gut da, im Vergleich zu anderen Länder, über die Wertschätzung der Wissenschaft, das ist wirklich toll. Also die Mehrheit der Deutschen finden Wissenschaft ein ganz essentielles Element ihrer Zukunft, ihrer Fähigkeit auch sicher zu sein, dass die Politik das richtige macht und so etwas. Sie haben Abwehrhaltungen, dass die Forschung vereinnahmt wird. Manchen Themen stellen wir uns sehr kritisch in Deutschland.
Gentechnisch veränderte Nahrung, Militärforschung und so weiter. Aber insgesamt ein sehr positives Bild der Wissenschaft. Das ist in anderen Ländern oft ganz anders. Aber wir wollen das gerne in Wissenschaft im Dialog weiter verfolgen und über die Zeit kommt da doch ein interessantes Lernen raus, wenn man rauskriegt, die ganze Mühe verändert die so auch den Umgang mit Themen oder verändert die auch das Bewusstsein der Menschen, was Wissenschaft ihnen bringt. Und das ist ein spannendes Projekt. Das sieht erst mal sehr simplistisch aus, wenn man diese einfachen Fragen sieht. Teile der Fragen überlappen mit derselben Erhebung, die die EU macht. So dass wir auch messen können, sind wir in Deutschland anders als die anderen europäischen Länder. Teile der Fragen sind auch wirklich dazu da, um rauszukriegen, gibt es vielleicht Themen, mit denen wir besser noch uns mehr beschäftigen sollen, weil da große Unsicherheit besteht? Und von daher finde ich das Wissenschaftsbarometer ist eine ganz einfache Idee, kostet nicht viel, aber hat auch sehr viel Feedback gegeben. Ist sehr in den Medien aufgegriffen worden, wird viel diskutiert, und das ist so auch ein Projekt, finde ich, was sehr gelungen ist, was eine gute Idee war, das einzuführen.
Wie oft findet dieses Befragung statt?
Das ist einmal im Jahr. Und man kann immer, ein paar Fragen werden immer gestellt, damit man auch über die Zeit einen Erkenntnisgewinn hat. Paar Fragen kann man immer zusätzlich dazu stellen. Paar Fragen haben auch mit unserer Selbstbewertung zu tun. Also nutzen Leute die ganzen Angebote, die überhaupt jetzt auf dem Markt sind und so etwas.
Wer wird gefragt?
Bürger. Also es ist per Zufall Telefonanrufe. Macht eine professionelle Umfragefirma für uns. Also damit das gesichert ist auch in der Methodik.
Ich sehe hier gerade zwei Umfragen 2014.
Ja das ist sogar zweimal im Jahr, kann sein ja. Also ist ziemlich neu, und so richtig bringt es was über die Zeit, wenn man sehen kann, verändert sich da was, bleibt es gleich? Es ist natürlich jetzt nicht so, dass wir über diese generelle Umfrage rauskriegen, was hat jetzt genau Wissenschaft im Dialog gebracht, weil es ja noch viele andere Kommunikation die ganze Zeit gibt, weil ja auch das Bildungsfernsehen einen riesigen Anteil hat an der Wissenschaftskommunikation. Aber es ist ein gutes Projekt und es wird wirklich sehr gut aufgegriffen und diskutiert. Und das finde ich ganz gut, dass wir so was betreiben.
Ja, Frau Boetius, ich glaube jetzt haben wir es.
Ja.
Also Wissenschaft im Dialog scheint ein sehr breit aufgestelltes Projekt zu sein. Es gibt eine ganze Menge zu rauszubekommen. Ich habe parallel hier viel nochmal in der Webseite herum geklickt, ist alles ganz wohl dokumentiert und es gibt einen Veranstaltungskalender und ist auch für die einzelnen Projekte, wo es Veranstaltungen gibt, entsprechende Kalender bzw. Was wir schon erwähnt haben, auch in dieser Citizen Science Datenbank noch Möglichkeiten, nach Projekte zu suchen, um sich da irgendwie selber einzubringen. Ja ansonsten müssen wir noch die Wissenschaftsjournalisten am Forum Wissenschaftskommunikation teilzunehmen.
Und die Wissenschaftsmanager noch mehr sich damit zu beschäftigen. Ja was ich auch interessant finde, dass so eine Debatte läuft, warum kennen so wenig Leute Wissenschaft im Dialog. Also wenn man so an die Uni oder wenn ich meine Doktoranden frage, haben die manchmal nichts davon gehört, aber das ist schon wichtig, weil es soll ja echt nicht drum gehen, so eine riesen Marke aufzubauen, die jetzt parallel zu allen anderen Aktivitäten als Marke vorangetrieben wird.
Nicht so ein fetziger Titel. Das klingt so trocken.
Wissenschaft im Dialog?
Wir haben eine coole, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das öffentlich sagen darf, aber wir haben eine sehr lustige Klausursitzung gehabt, wo es drum ging, was ist Wissenschaft im Dialog in 10 und 20 und 50 Jahren von heute. Und irgendeiner hat die lustige Idee gehabt, dann heißt es irgendwann Wissenschaft im Monolog. Und darum geht es doch. Wir haben sehr viel Monolog in der Wissenschaft und wir müssen da raus. Und einfach mal ausprobieren zu können, das mussten sich viele erkämpfen und deswegen ist Wissenschaft im Dialog finde ich eine super Sache, weil es jetzt mal nicht in erster Linie um den Wettbewerb geht, sondern weil es ums Ausprobieren geht. Um auch ein paar Risikoprojekte, um ein buntes Durcheinander. Und davon haben alle was, die sich beteiligen und das macht Spaß, das alles nacheinander kennenzulernen und auszuprobieren und dann natürlich aber auch bewerten zu können, zu sagen, Mensch das lohnt sich jetzt nicht so oder das können andere besser, das ist alles interessant. Also ich bin da selber noch ganz beim Lernen und habe mir aber vorgenommen, nacheinander bei all den Sachen mal selber mitzumachen, auch um überhaupt informiert reden zu können. Was ist das, wie fühlt sich das an?
Ja.
Ja noch viel Spaß dabei.
Danke.
Vielen Dank für den Dialog hier an dieser Stelle.
Ich hoffe, es war nicht zu sehr Monolog?
Nein überhaupt nicht. Wir suchen ja hier auch den Dialog und von daher bedanke ich mich natürlich auch bei den Hörern hier von Forschergeist. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter, ich sage tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.